Do you want anything? One second, I just want to... Do you want something? Okay. Can I get one crispy chicken? Two crispy chicken for you. Because I don't... You want two for yourself.
你要吃点什么吗？等一下，我只是想……你想要点什么吗？好吧。我能来一个香脆鸡块吗？给你来两个香脆鸡块。因为我不……你自己想要两个。
Okay. No judgment. That's fine. And ice cream. Do you guys even serve... You know what? Do you mind if we just do this after? Okay, no judgment. That's fine. And ice cream. Do you guys even serve... You know what? Do you mind if we just do this after?
好吧。绝不评判。没关系。还有冰淇淋。你们甚至还供应……你知道吗？你介意我们待会儿再弄这个吗？好吧，绝不评判。没关系。还有冰淇淋。你们甚至还供应……你知道吗？你介意我们待会儿再弄这个吗？
Welcome, it's an all-new SmartList. SmartList. SmartList. SmartList. We were just talking about Shawshank and I was gonna say to Will, Jay Bertori came on, that my philosophy in life is kind of. Oh, this is good, hang on. No, this is good. This is good.
欢迎收听全新一期的 SmartList。SmartList。SmartList。SmartList。我们刚才还在聊《肖申克的救赎》，我本来想对威尔说，杰·巴托里来过节目，我的人生哲学有点像。哦，这个好，等一下。不，这个很好。这个很好。
You like to get the pen out. Yeah, everybody pull over and get out the pen. By the way, this is Shawshank Redemption, I think, for Tracy, the film. So the end of the movie, so the whole movie, Morgan Freeman is talking about, he goes in front of the, what do they call it, the panel or whatever, the people who kind of,
你喜欢把笔拿出来。对，大家把车停靠在路边，把笔拿出来。顺便说一句，我觉得对于崔西来说，这就是《肖申克的救赎》这部电影。所以电影的结尾，整部电影里，摩根·弗里曼一直在说话，他走到那个，他们叫什么来着，评审团还是什么的面前，就是那种负责，
the board, yeah, and he's the parole board, and he's like, he tells them what they think they wanna hear, he's like, no, I've been reformed, I'm good, I've learned my lesson. And they always deny his parole. And then at the end of the movie, he finally just is like, you know what, fuck it. This is who I am, you people are crazy,
董事会，对，也就是假释委员会，他就告诉他们那些他们想听的话，他说，不，我已经改过自新了，我很好，我已经吸取教训了。但他们总是拒绝他的假释。然后到了电影结尾，他终于忍不住说，你知道吗，去他妈的。我就是这样的人，你们这群疯子，
I didn't learn anything, blah, blah. And then that's when he gets released. That's it. That's my philosophy for life. And that's what full release comes from honesty. Well, two ways, sorry. So everybody go ahead and put your car back in drive and toss that paper either out the window
我什么都没学到，巴拉巴拉。然后就在这个时候他获释了。就是这样。这就是我的人生哲学。而真正的释放来自于诚实。嗯，有两种方式，抱歉。所以大家把车挂回前进档，把那张纸要么扔出窗外，
if you still have an ashtray in the car, use that. Because we really didn't get an end to it. It's nice that Sean's philosophy on life is like, you know, like, don't try to be something you're not. Yeah, exactly. Right, I agree with you. Authenticity is a thematic that I'm on a project that I'm working on right now.
如果你车里还有烟灰缸的话，就用那个。因为我们其实没有看到结局。肖恩的人生哲学真好，就像是，你知道的，不要试图去扮演一个不真实的自己。对，没错。对，我同意你的看法。真实性是我目前正在参与的一个项目的主题。
Oh yeah, very good. That's the theme of the thing. Oh, very good. It's a great evergreen, yeah. Authenticity. Hey Jason. Yeah, hi. Why did the man fall down the well?
哦，对，非常好。这就是那个东西的主题。哦，非常棒。这是一个很棒的常青话题，对吧。真实性。嘿，杰森。对，嗨。那个人为什么掉进井里？
Oh boy. Because he didn't see that well. That's exactly right. Oh. Wait, who, wait, Willie, you got, when we had Jordan Peele on his film, Nope, I always just thought it was just a fun way to say, yeah, no, I'm not comfortable with flying saucers,
哦，天哪。因为他没看清那口井。完全正确。哦。等等，谁，等等，威利，你懂的，当乔丹·皮尔来我们的节目宣传他的电影《不！》时，我一直以为那只是一个有趣的说法，意思是，对，不，我对飞碟感到不舒服，
it says the main character, and this shit freaks me out. But it's actually an acronym for? It's an acronym, well he said it's an acronym. And I just went, and I thought about it for two seconds, I went, not of planet Earth. Not of planet Earth. I remember the look on his face, he was a little mad I think.
主角在片中这么说，这破玩意儿吓死我了。但它其实是一个缩略词，代表？它是一个缩略词，嗯，他说这是一个缩略词。我当时就想了，想了两秒钟，我说，不是来自地球。不是来自地球。我记得他当时脸上的表情，我想他有点生气。
Well, no, what you were seeing was the same look that I had, which is total shock at your level of intelligence. Like just like, stunning surprise. That's what hurt me the most was the stunning, the stunned look on everybody's face when I do something. Well, we're gonna have a stunned look at your guest when he comes home. Well, he's gonna have a stunned look at Sean.
嗯，不，你看到的其实和我当时的表情一样，那就是对你的智商水平感到彻底震惊。就像那种，惊呆了的惊讶。最伤我心的就是当我做什么事时，大家脸上那种惊呆了、目瞪口呆的表情。好吧，等他回家时，我们也会对你的嘉宾露出这种目瞪口呆的表情。好吧，他对肖恩也会有这种目瞪口呆的表情。
Sorry Sean, did you have a lunch? He's gonna have a stunned look at your, when he heard your joke for sure, because he tells jokes for a living. Oh, shit. Yeah. Here we go. And he doesn't just tell jokes. Man, this guy tells jokes.
抱歉，肖恩，你吃午饭了吗？他听到你的笑话时绝对会大吃一惊，因为他可是靠讲笑话谋生的。哦，操。对。我们开始吧。而且他不仅仅是讲笑话。天哪，这家伙太会讲笑话了。
This son of a gun. This son of a gun, and that's kind of the language that he would use too, son of a gun. Dax Shepard's coming back. He, Dax does love son of a gun. He does. This guy uses, I don't know,
这个王八蛋。这个王八蛋，这也是他会用的那种口头禅，王八蛋。戴克斯·夏pard要来了。他，戴克斯确实很喜欢“王八蛋”这个词。他确实喜欢。这家伙用，我不知道，
there's something about his everything that he does, his delivery, his turn of phrase, the things he talks about, the way he does it. A lot of people call him the nicest guy in stand up. I think of him as just the funniest dude I've seen in such a long time. And I remember the first time I heard about him
他的一言一行、他的表达方式、他的措辞、他谈论的事情以及他做事的方式都有种独特的魅力。很多人称他为单口喜剧界最好的人。我觉得他是我见过很久以来最搞笑的家伙。我记得我第一次听说他，
was through our old friend, Greg Garcia. Yeah. Yeah, and Greg was like, Greg reached out to me, he's like, you have to have this guy on blah blah blah and I made some glib remark, he's like, you're gonna regret it. I go, I think he's hilarious, relax Greg. And then JB, you and I had the pleasure of meeting him really, really briefly. I'm gonna make you repeat the glib remark right in front of you. We met him really briefly up at, last year up at Pebble Beach and he's as nice as he is funny
是通过我们的老朋友格雷格·加西亚。对。对，格雷格当时就，格雷格联系我，他说，你一定要请这家伙来上节目，巴拉巴拉，然后我随口敷衍了一句，他说，你会后悔的。我说，我觉得他挺搞笑的，格雷格，放松点。然后杰比，你和我曾有幸非常非常短暂地见过他。我要让你当面重复你当时敷衍的那句话。我们去年在圆石滩很短暂地见过他，他既善良又搞笑，
and it's all I love this guy he's so funny I love the Tennessee kid I love the Tennessee kid I love his new special hello world on Amazon he's about to go on tour in a new one guys it's none other than the hilarious Nate Borgazzi. Nate Borgazzi! Hello. Even better. Hey. I was ready for Ray. I love him.
我太喜欢这家伙了，他太搞笑了，我爱田纳西小子，我爱田纳西小子，我爱他在亚马逊上的新专场《你好世界》，他马上就要开始新一期巡演了，伙计们，他不是别人，正是搞笑的内特·巴尔加齐。内特·巴尔加齐！你好。更好。嘿。我本来准备好迎接雷了。我爱他。
Nate Borgazzi. I'll get Ray. Oh, how great. Nate, it's good to see you again. Good to see you, Sean. Hey, just a little fun note, never seen Shawshank, so. That's, wow. Well, you're young.
内特·巴尔加齐。我会去找雷的。哦，太棒了。内特，很高兴再次见到你。很高兴见到你，肖恩。嘿，顺便说个有趣的事，我从来没看过《肖申克的救赎》，所以。那是，哇。好吧，你还年轻。
You're too young for it. You know, it's before your time. Wait, wait, how old? I'm 44. I should have. It's pretty young. You're too young for it. You know, it's before your time. You're wait, wait, how old 44? I should have hit young. You know what Nate? I didn't see Shawshank till I was 45. Oh, I'll do it next Anyway, yeah, Nate Varghese Nate Nate This is really nice great to see you again because we did meet. Yeah, we did meet up at Pebble Yep, do you live in a nice house or you you in a nice hotel room? Where are you? In a hotel room.
你太年轻了，没看过。你知道，那是你出生之前的事。等等，等等，多大？我44岁了。我本应该看过的。挺年轻的。你太年轻了，没看过。你知道，那是你出生之前的事。你等等，等等，44岁？我应该算年轻的。你知道吗，内特？我45岁才看《肖申克的救赎》。哦，我下次再看。不管怎样，嘿，内特·巴尔加齐，内特，内特，真的很高兴再次见到你，因为我们确实见过。对，我们去年在圆石滩见过。没错，你住在好房子里还是漂亮的酒店房间里？你在哪？在酒店房间里。
I'm in Syracuse. Okay. Working? I got a show in Syracuse. This is, can't make it here. Can't make it anywhere, you know? That's what they say. That's what they say.
我在锡拉丘兹。好的。在工作？我在锡拉丘兹有场演出。这地方，在这混不下去。在哪都混不下去，你知道吗？他们都这么说。他们都这么说。
I like, Nate, I like that Sean said, you said I'm in Syracuse and Sean goes, working? Nah. No. Just. He's just hanging out with the orange man. This is the vacations I can afford. He goes, it's nice, we took a bus.
内特，我喜欢肖恩刚才说的，你说我在锡拉丘兹，然后肖恩问，在工作？不。没有。就是。他只是跟那个穿橙色衣服的家伙一起闲逛。这就是我负担得起的假期。他说，挺好的，我们坐了辆大巴。
We spent on the hotel room. Yeah, everything went to this. I have a family of 30s right off camera. They're just right there. I said, if y'all talk during this, I will kill you. When you are traveling around you doing these shows, what size is your group footprint? What's your posse size?
钱都花在酒店房间上了。对，全都花在这上面了。镜头外有一家子30口人。他们就在那儿。我说，你们谁要是敢在录音时说话，我就宰了你们。当你在各地巡演办这些演出时，你的团队规模有多大？你的随行人员有多少？
We have probably like 10 guys. Because I bring four openers. Actually tonight, we got a surprise opener. He won't be here until later. Jimmy Fallon. Fallon is coming to the show Oh, that's great. He's going to jump on the bus. Where do I know it? Tell me what we've been know him from that movie
我们大概有10个人左右。因为我带了四个暖场嘉宾。其实今晚，我们有一个惊喜暖场嘉宾。他要晚点才会来。吉米·法伦。法伦要来看演出。哦，太棒了。他要上大巴。我怎么会知道他？告诉我我们是从哪部电影里认识他的，
pitch fever Jimmy right now by the way, he's hearing this he's sharpening his knife hearing us say this one day I have to say this, we developed the show together years ago. What? And you were very successful then, but to see you over the years, just kind of like, and then SNL,
《急速狂飙》吉米，顺便说一句，他现在听到这些了，他正在磨刀呢，听到我们这么说。总有一天我必须说，我们多年前一起开发过这个节目。什么？你那时就已经很成功了，但这些年来看着你，就像是，然后是周六夜现场（SNL），
and then like, it's so exciting to finally be like, yes, this guy has been brilliant, has always been brilliant, and now more and more people can see it. And you sell, Nate, you sell out arenas, like 20,000 at a clip, which is just unbelievable, and on top of this, and I'm gonna say this, and I've said it a bunch since it aired, when you were on SNL,
然后就像是，终于能说“太棒了，这家伙一直都很才华横溢，现在越来越多的人能看到了”，这种感觉太令人兴奋了。而且你，内特，你的门票场场卖光，比如每次都是两万人的体育馆，这简直难以置信，除此之外，我要说的是，自从节目播出后我已经说过好多次了，你在《周六夜现场》里的表演，
your sketch, your George Washington sketch, is to me, just in my opinion, the funniest SNL sketch I've seen in 15 years. Oh wow, I'm gonna look that up. I totally agree with that remark when you know your TV just went on which tells me I don't know what I turned on the fam the family's board. Yeah, the 30 men are getting itchy There's no one in just you and Jim Benheim, right? No, no, let's give me something to watch But you have to echo what Sean saying you have just like kind of finally thank thankfully the rest of America is just like
你的那个小品，你的乔治·华盛顿小品，在我看来，仅仅是我个人的看法，是我15年来看过最好笑的《周六夜现场》小品。哦，哇，我要去搜来看看。我完全同意这个评价，当你发现你的电视突然打开了，这说明我不知道自己打开了什么，家里的长辈们。对，那30个男人开始按捺不住了。除了你和吉姆·本海姆，屋里没有别人了吧？不，不，给我找点能看的东西。但你得附和肖恩的话，你真的就像是，谢天谢地，全美国的人终于开始，
Understand what an awesome awesome hilarious dude you are so how do you start you're the Tennessee kid you're from? Old hickory, Tennessee am I right about that yes old hickory old hickory is it next to new hickory? No news a little bit was it ever new Hickory. Yeah, Old Hickory. Is it next to New Hickory? No, news is a little bit farther. Was it ever New Hickory? No, it was date old. He's got this great joke in his new special on Amazon Prime where he says, I'm from Old Hickory, it's where Andrew Jackson's from, and people are like, he wasn't a good guy,
明白你是一个多么棒、多么搞笑的家伙了，所以你是怎么开始的？你是田纳西小子，你来自田纳西州老山核桃镇，我没记错吧？是的，老山核桃镇。老山核桃镇旁边是新山核桃镇吗？不，新镇要远一点。曾经有过新山核桃镇吗？对，就是老山。他在亚马逊 Prime 的新专场里有一个超棒的笑话，他说，我来自老山核桃镇，那是安德鲁·杰克逊的故乡，人们就会说，他可不是个好人，
and Nate goes, well, we didn't know him that well, but we didn't know him at all. It's hilarious joke. But Nate, talk to me about when you were a kid and stuff, like did you, were you always into comedy? Did you watch SNL? Like what were your inspirations? That's what I was thinking, that's what I was getting to me about when you were a kid and stuff. Did you always into comedy? Did you watch SNL? What were your inspirations? That's what I was thinking.
然后内特就会说，嗯，我们跟他不是很熟，其实我们根本不认识他。这是个超级搞笑的笑话。不过内特，跟我聊聊你小时候的事呗，比如说，你一直都对喜剧感兴趣吗？你看《周六夜现场》吗？你的灵感来源是什么？我刚才想的就是这个，我正想问你小时候的事。你一直对喜剧感兴趣吗？你看《周六夜现场》吗？你的灵感来源是什么？我刚才就在想这个。
That's what I was getting to. How did you start? I just got there fast enough. My dad's a magician. What? And does comedy. Mine too. Mine can disappear in the drop of a hat.
这正是我要说的。你是怎么开始的？我只是切入得够快。我爸是个魔术师。什么？而且还表演喜剧。我爸也是。我爸一转眼就能消失得无影无踪。
Sean Hayes, you are talk show quick. Get out of here. Sorry, Nate. Thanks, you guys. Keep going. No, I grew up around that. I mean, so that was like, you know, it was funny but then also growing up around, you know,
肖恩·海斯，你接梗的速度太快了。滚开吧。抱歉，内特。谢谢你们，伙计们。继续。不，我从小就在那种环境里长. 大。我的意思是，所以那就好像是，你知道的，既搞笑，但同时又在那种环境中长大，
my dad being a magician. You learned pattern. Yeah, it just kind of leads you to it, I guess. Wait, wait, wait, so Nate, so you grew up, your dad's a magician, he obviously loved you, sorry Sean, and he, I mean to the extent that he wanted to stick around. I'm friends with Sean's dad.
我爸是个魔术师。你学会了套路。对，这自然而然就把你引向了这条路，我想。等等，等等，等等，所以内特，也就是说你长大的时候，你爸是个魔术师，他显然很爱你，抱歉肖恩，而且他，我是说他对你的爱体现在他愿意留在家里。我和肖恩的爸爸是朋友。
Yeah. Oh, so you know where he is. Yeah around. I'm friends with Sean's dad. Yeah. Oh, so you know where he is. Yeah, yeah, he's a pretty good dude. I go out. He gives you. Yeah. I don't know the whole backstory,
哦，所以你知道他在哪。对，在附近。我和肖恩的爸爸是朋友。对。哦，所以你知道他在哪。对，对，他是个挺不错的家伙。我经常出去。他会给你。对。我不知道全部的内幕，
but I know, I just know from what R hanging out. He's got no tread left on his tires, but he's a good guy. He's, he's sex you a pin to his location. So what was that like growing up with your dad being a magician? That's pretty rad. An illusionist.
但我知道，我只是从我们一起闲逛了解到的。他轮胎上的花纹都快磨光了，但他是个好家伙。他，他把他的实时位置发给你了。所以，在一个魔术师父亲身边长大是什么体验？那太酷了。一个幻觉大师。
Yeah, yeah, it was the best. You know, I don't know if I even understood it. I'm sure, I think of it like, you have my daughter and I'm sure your kids, it doesn't seem not normal. Like it just felt like it's like that's all I ever knew. And it wasn't until you got older that you're like, yeah dude, nobody's dad's a magician. Yeah. Yeah.
对，对，那真是太棒了。你知道的，我甚至不知道自己当时是否理解。我敢肯定，我觉得就像，你有了女儿，而且我确信你也有孩子，这看起来并不不正常。就感觉这就像是我所知道的一切。直到你长大了，你才会想，对啊老兄，根本没人爸爸是魔术师。对。对。
Start saying you don't know when you're asked what your dad does. Right. Yeah. So he would make the living, dude. I mean, I have people do magic, like magicians would show me magic tricks. I've just seen them all too.
当别人问你爸爸是做什么的时候，你开始不知道该怎么回答。对。对。所以他以此为生，老兄。我的意思是，我见过别人变魔术，魔术师会给我变魔术。我也全都看过了。
And I just, I'm just not a good person to perform for because I'm just like, all right. You know, it's like, is this your card? You's always by it's always my car it's always been my every time I see magic every time I see magic I freaking love it and I'll bet everybody listening loves it well I mean how can you not love when you see a magic trick I mean a good one a good one but I but I never think about it I never and I always make fun of it when I hear about it. It's like you hear about mimes.
而且我，我真的不是一个适合当观众的人，因为我只会想，好吧。你知道的，就像是，这是你的牌吗？每次都是它，每次都是我的牌，每次我看到魔术，每次我看到魔术我都超级喜欢，我敢打赌每个听节目的人也都喜欢，我的意思是，看到魔术表演时怎么能不喜欢的，我是说一个精彩的魔术，一个精彩的魔术，但我从不深入去想，我从来不，每次听到有人说起魔术我都会嘲笑它。就像你听说哑剧一样。
But you know what, you can't take your eyes off a mime. Or a magician. It gets a bad rap. You can't take your eyes off a mime. Yeah, that's the quote of the day. Wait, so Nate, so your dad, Sean was gonna ask this, so your dad made a living as a magician. He did, he was a teacher too.
但你知道吗，你根本无法把视线从哑剧演员身上移开。魔术师也是。这行名声不太好。你根本无法把视线从哑剧演员身上移开。对，这就是今日金句。等等，所以内特，也就是说你爸爸，肖恩刚才正要问这个，所以你爸爸是以变魔术为生的。是的，他同时也是个老师。
So he had a day job and then he would do that. And then we were always in Nashville. And so he's just always done it. And I mean, he's very successful. He's very known in the magic world. He comes with me and opens for me a lot on the road. No way. We'll do these shows.
所以他有一份正职，然后兼职变魔术。而且我们一直住在纳什维尔。所以他一直都在做这个。我的意思是，他非常成功。他在魔术界非常有名。他经常跟我一起去，在我的巡演上为我做暖场。不会吧。我们会一起做这些演出。
And it's every little boy's dream, travel to your dad when you're 44 years old. So we got a little CPAP machine hooked up in a tour bus. It's a good time. You got some ramps on the side of that stage? Yeah, I mean we had our bus parked out one time and it was my dad, my mom, and my aunt, and I was like, people probably go by this tour bus
这可以说是每个小男孩的梦想，44岁了还能跟爸爸一起去巡演。所以我们在巡演大巴上装了一台小型持续正压呼吸机（CPAP）。那可真是段好时光。你舞台旁边有斜坡吗？对，我是说有一次我们把大巴停在外面，里面有我爸、我妈和我阿姨，我就想，人们路过这辆巡演大巴时，
and they're like, it's pretty rockin' in there. And I mean, we got, it's lights off, quiet, just the roar of machines keeping everybody alive. And the smell of liniment. Wait, so did you ever perform in the magic shows with your dad? I did some, yeah. I would help him with magic.
大概会觉得里面一定在疯狂摇滚吧。但实际上，里面灯全关着，安安静静的，只有维持大家生命的机器的轰鸣声。还有风湿膏药的味道。等等，那你以前有没有跟你爸一起在魔术表演里登台过？我确实演过一些，对。我会帮他变魔术。
You ever get cut in half? No, no, we didn't ever do that. We didn't, he never did that, go that far. He did a slight hand. A lot of slight hand and he does he does calm. That's my favorite Yeah, so then when you what what age were you when you were like? Actually kind of to what Jason you kind of alluded to but did you start just like being a wise ass on the on the side of Your dad's stage while he was doing magic like is that how stand-up started for you?
你有没有被电锯分尸过？不，不，我们从来没做过那个。我们没有，他从来没做过，没走那么远。他玩的是手法。很多近景手法，而且他很搞笑。那是我的最爱。对，那当你，你多大年纪的时候，开始有这种想法？实际上有点像杰森刚才暗示的那样，你是不是开始在，你爸在变魔术时，在他的舞台旁边当一个聪明的捣蛋鬼？你的单口喜剧就是这样开始的吗？
uh, I Think it was just being funny. We would like I remember how stand-up started for you? I think it was just being funny. We would, like, I remember seeing stand-up. It was just trying to, it was trying to make people laugh. I don't think I ever really made fun of anybody. Right. But it was like I would make fun of myself a lot, which is what I do now in my comedy show. Yeah, that's the best.
呃，我想，那只是因为好玩。我们会像，我记得单口喜剧是怎么开始的吗？我想那只是因为好玩。我们会像，我记得我看到过单口喜剧。那只是为了逗大家笑。我觉得我从来没有真正去嘲笑过任何人。对。但我就像会经常自嘲，这也是我现在在喜剧演出中做的事。对，那是最好的。
It'd be like, you'd be doing stuff like that, making funny. He had, I mean one time, I've talked about this in a special on one of them, but it was like he brought the Easter Bunny home when I was like six. He was at a mall doing a show, and the Easter Bunny needed a ride home. And my dad goes, I'll give you a ride home
你就会做那样的事，真搞笑。他有一次，我在某个专场里聊过这个，我大概六岁的时候，他把复活节兔子带回了家。他在一个商场里演出，复活节兔子需要搭车回家。我爸就说，如果你顺路去我家的话，
if you swing by my house. And so I remember the Easter Bunny, we had like, my parents had this old red Mazda stick shift, you know, and the Easter Bunny's head was bent to the side because his head couldn't fit in the car. So he was just, he was sitting like this and then he got out and I met the Easter Bunny and then my dad drove the Easter Bunny home. So that started your, the Easter Bunny, you say, started? Yeah, that was the trajectory. I go, all right. I go, if I can beat that guy,
我可以载你一程。所以我还记得复活节兔子，我们家有一辆我父母开的红色马自达手动挡汽车，你知道的，复活节兔子的头是歪向一边的，因为他的头塞不进车里。所以他就那样坐着，然后他下了车，我见到了复活节兔子，然后我爸把复活节兔子送回家了。所以那就是你的开端，你觉得复活节兔子是这一切的开端？对，那就是我的职业轨迹。我当时想，好吧。我说，如果我能打败那个家伙，
then maybe I can make it as a stand up. Now, what was your mom's attitude on her husband's career? My parents have been together since seventh grade, and they, my mom's very funny, but she worked at a bank. I mean, she's just been, I mean, it's just stuff. There's like, growing up, it's buying, you know, she has to go up to my dad and be like,
那也许我能成为一名单口喜剧演员。那么，你妈妈对她丈夫的职业是什么态度？我父母从七年级就在一起了，他们，我妈妈非常幽默，但她在银行工作。我的意思是，她一直都在，我的意思是，就是那些琐事。就像成长过程中，买东西，你知道的，她必须走到我爸爸面前说，
go to the store, I need you to buy 12 lemons. And he has to buy it for like his magic, or a bunch of newspapers from that day. It's like a bunch of random, and it's just normal conversations. You're just like, it's a Tuesday. You're just trying to grab some bread, milk, and 30 oranges, and then you get on out of there.
去商店，我需要你买12个柠檬。他必须为他的魔术去买这些，或者买一大堆当天的报纸。就像是一堆乱七八糟的东西，这只是很平常的对话。你就会觉得，这只是个周二。你只是想顺便买点面包、牛奶和30个橙子，然后就赶紧离开那儿。
And handkerchiefs in six colors. You've got a lot of shows this week. So. It's just stuff like that. That's cool. Wait, wait, so Nate, so I want to kind of get, again, this is, we're the worst interviewers on the planet. We were just voted worst ever interviewers.
还有六种颜色的手帕。你这周有好多演出要赶。所以。就是诸如此类的事情。这挺酷的。等等，等等，所以内特，所以我想了解，再次声明，我们是地球上最烂的主持人。我们刚刚被评为史上最烂主持人。
We nailed it. Of all time. But I want to go back, because we, again, because you play these huge Arenas and it's amazing and I don't I don't know if I've ever seen a comic so Comfortable you make it so intimate even though you're playing a huge there's something about it that makes it so personal and you and you You're so organic. Yeah, you draw us in as opposed to ask every time about authenticity You're very authentic. But you... that feels like you... that...
我们做到了。有史以来最烂。但我想要回到之前的话题，因为我们，再次声明，因为你在这么巨大的体育馆里演出，这太惊人了，而且我不知道我是否见过哪个喜剧演员能如此松弛。你让演出变得如此亲切，尽管你面对的是一个巨大的场地，但总有某种东西让它变得如此私密，而且你，你，你是如此的自然。对，你把我们吸引了进去，而不是像其他人那样每次都大谈特谈真实性，你非常真实。但你……这感觉就像你……那……
When you started, you must have started in clubs, like in smaller venues, right? Like most comics, I imagine. Oh, yeah. So I moved to Chicago first for a couple years. And then I moved to New York. And I was in New York for the most, for like eight and a half years. And so I did all the clubs and all the, like, going up every single night. I performed for one guy once. Oh my gosh, no way.
你刚开始的时候，肯定是从俱乐部开始的，比如在较小的场地，对吧？就像大多数喜剧演员一样，我猜。哦，对。所以我先搬去芝加哥住了几年。然后我搬到了纽约。我在纽约住了大部分时间，大概八年半。所以我演遍了所有的俱乐部，所有的，比如每天晚上都登台。我曾经只为一个观众表演过一次。哦天哪，不会吧。
Like he wouldn't leave. We tried to get him to leave and he's like, nah, it's all right. And we were like, well, we don't think it's all right. And so I'm like, he really wasn't about him. You're like, what's up? I was like, I don't want to stand up in front of a guy. Regularly up in front of four people, five, six,
就像他赖着不走。我们试图让他离开，而他说，不，没关系。然后我们说，嗯，我们觉得没关系。所以我心想，他根本不是冲着我来的。你会想，怎么回事？我当时想，我才不要在一个观众面前说单口喜剧。经常在四个人、五个人、六个人面前表演，
like, I mean, six people was like, got a pretty good show going on. You know, you were excited about six people. No way. Yeah, so you just get used to just being in these kind of, like, you know, it takes a long time before you're in front of, like, an actual paying crowd that's good. But what does that do for you, like, rhythm-wise,
比如，六个人就已经算是一场相当不错的演出了。你知道的，你当时会为六个人感到兴奋。不会吧。对，所以你慢慢就习惯了在这些，你知道的，要过很长一段时间，你才能真正在一群买票且不错的观众面前表演。但这对你来说意味着什么，比如在节奏方面，
et cetera, when you're just doing six people? Like... Well, I had to learn to get people into my rhythm very quickly. So since I'm talk slower and I was from the South and all this, I had to figure out, because I would follow like high energy acts, and then I'd come up and I'm like,
等等，当你只面对六个人表演时？就像……好吧，我不得不学会如何迅速把观众带入我的节奏。因为我语速比较慢，而且我来自南方诸如此类的，我必须找出应对方法，因为我通常会排在高能量的演员后面登台，然后我上台就会想，
well, I gotta come up with a joke or I gotta say something. I just need you to hear my voice for a second so you can go like, all right, readjust and be like, now we're in this rhythm and then get into the first kind of, come up with a good opening little thing or whatever and just get rolling.
好吧，我得想个笑话或者说点什么。我只需要你们听我说一秒钟的声音，这样你们就会觉得，好吧，重新调整一下，然后心想，现在我们进入这个节奏了，接着切入第一种开场小段或者别的什么，然后顺利开讲。
You know what always blows my mind about standups though? How you can just walk around the stage for two hours and always have something to talk about. Is it like a monologue you memorize? Or like how can you just go up and speak funny for two hours straight? Yeah, Sean, where do you get a load of her? He's gonna love show business, he's gonna love it.
你知道单口喜剧演员最让我惊叹的是什么吗？你们怎么能随随便便在舞台上走来走去两个小时，而且总有东西可讲？这是像背诵独白一样吗？还是说你怎么能直接上台连续两个小时不停地讲好笑的事？对啊，肖恩，你觉得她怎么样？他一定会爱上秀场生意的，他绝对会喜欢的。
Two thirds of the planet is water. There's a couple of poles. No, you know what I mean, that always blows my mind. Obviously you had material that you work on, but do you ever like- There's your answer. Go up and you're like, oh my God, I don't know what subject to talk about next.
地球上有三分之二都是水。还有几个极地。不，你知道的我的意思，那总是让我惊叹。当然你有你琢磨过的内容，但你会不会有时——这就是你的答案。上台后心想，天哪，我不知道接下来该聊什么话题了。
Like the flow of it. Well I don't go up. Yeah, I go up prepared. I mean, I can't do the other, I can't really do like crowd work and go up and stuff. It's very, very- He's not freestylin' bro. No I know.
就像那种流畅度。好吧，我不会即兴发挥的。对，我是做足准备才上台的。我的意思是，我做不到别的，我真的不会什么现场互动然后直接上台之类的。这非常非常——他可不是在自由freestyle，老兄。不，我知道。
He's been workin' on it for months. I know but it's just- But Nate, do you ever switch the order based on the audience? Oh, yeah, this new hour, I've switched it a ton. But it's worked, because now I'm opening on a joke that I have closed on. So it's like, it's great to be opening on a joke
他已经琢磨了好几个月了。我知道，但这只是——不过内特，你有没有根据观众的反应临时调整顺序？哦，会呀，这套新的一个小时的内容，我调整了超多。但效果很好，因为我现在把一个我以前用来压轴的笑话拿来当开场了。所以感觉就是，用一个我必须展现出压轴能量和节奏的笑话来开场感觉太棒了，然后你把它提到前面来。而且你是在飞行途中临时做这些决定的。对，你全凭感觉拿捏。这有点像一首歌。我现在对单口喜剧爱得深沉。我太喜欢它了。
that I've actually had to have the energy and the rhythm of a closer, and then you just move it up, and now it's the front. And you're doing those decisions on the fly. Yeah, you just fill it out. It's kind of like a song. I'm in love with stand-up right now. I love it so much.
我其实不得不具备终结者的精力和节奏，然后你只要把它提前，现在它成了最前沿。你得当场做出这些决定。是的，你只需要把它填满。这有点像一首歌。我现在对单口喜剧爱不释手。我太喜欢它了。
And the way I've looked at writing kind of is like, it's a movie. So I'm the main character of this movie, and I'm telling the story. There's a reason for me saying all this stuff. And everything leads into the other thing. So you want to make it where people don't realize you're into another joke.
我对待写作的方式有点像是在拍电影。所以我是这部电影的主角，我在讲故事。我讲所有这些内容都是有原因的。每一部分都环环相扣。所以你想让大家不知不觉中已经过渡到了下一个笑话。
But in my head, I could be on like joke five. But I'm trying to make it where like, and then that's how you remember it, because the only way, if you're talking about like riding a car, and then you're like, and then that's how you remember it, because the only way, you know, if you're talking about like riding a car, and then you're like, my wife bought a car. Well, now that's the only thing I could go into. Right, right.
但在我的脑海里，我可能已经在讲第五个笑话了。但我努力做到让观众觉得，然后这就是你记住它的方式，因为唯一的办法，如果你在谈论开车出行，然后你就会想，然后这就是你记住它的方式，因为唯一的办法，你知道的，如果你在谈论买车，然后你说，我妻子买了一辆车。好吧，现在那成了我唯一能接下去的话题。对，对。
And we will be right back. Thanks to Viori for supporting the show. Tired of the same old workout clothes? I am. I'm also tired of working out, but I'm going to do it. Then you need to check out Viori. Viori is your destination for high-performance active wear that's designed to look and feel great. Their pieces aren't just for the gym. They're so comfortable and stylish you'll want to wear them all day long.
我们马上回来。感谢 Viori 对本节目录制的支持。厌倦了千篇一律的运动服吗？我也是。我也厌倦了去健身，但我还是得去。那么你需要了解一下 Viori。Viori 是你购买高性能运动服装的首选目的地，其设计旨在带来出色的外观和穿着体验。他们的单品不仅仅适合去健身房。它们是如此舒适和时尚，你会想整天都穿着它们。
Viori's innovative fabrics and thoughtful design ensure maximum mobility and breathability no matter how intense your workout gets. But the best parts? Their active wear doesn't scream, I just came from the gym. Whether you're hitting the gym, running errands, or lounging at home, Viori has everything you need to look and feel your best. For me, I like the Transit Jogger, and the color I like it in is ink, INK.
Viori 创新的面料和周到的设计确保了最大的灵活性和透气性，无论你的锻炼多么剧烈。但最棒的部分是什么？他们的运动服不会大声宣告：“我刚从健身房出来。”无论你是去健身房、跑腿办事还是在家闲逛，Viori 都能满足你的所有需求，让你看起来和感觉都处于最佳状态。对我来说，我喜欢 Transit 慢跑裤，我最喜欢的颜色是墨水蓝，INK。
It's like a navy kind of color. But I love it because I wear sweatpants almost every single day, and I need a new one, so I got these Viori ones. Oh my God, I wear them immediately when I get out of bed, and I just wear them around the house or wear them to the store or wear them wherever I need to go and nobody knows the difference. They don't even question what my pants are, they just think they're really cool looking.
它有点像海军蓝的那种颜色。但我太喜欢它了，因为我几乎每天都穿运动裤，我需要一条新的，所以我买了这条 Viori 的裤子。哦天哪，我一起床就会立刻穿上它，然后我就穿着它在家里转悠，或者穿着它去商店，或者穿着它去任何我想去的地方，根本没人能看出区别。他们甚至不会怀疑我穿的是什么裤子，只会觉得这裤子看起来太酷了。
Viori is an investment in your happiness and they're hooking up smart list listeners with 20% off your first purchase at Viori.com slash smart list. That's a V-U-O-R-I dot com slash smart list. Not only will you receive 20% off your first purchase, but you'll also enjoy free shipping on any U.S. orders over $75 and free returns. Go to vuori.com slash smartless and discover the versatility of Viori clothing. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp.
投资 Viori 就是投资你的快乐，他们现在为 SmartList 的听众提供在 Viori.com/smartlist 首次购买享 8 折的优惠。网址是 V-U-O-R-I 点 com 斜杠 smartlist。你不仅能在首次购买时享受 8 折优惠，还能享受任何美国订单满 75 美元免运费以及免费退货服务。快去 vuori.com/smartlist 探索 Viori 服饰的多变风格吧。本节目由 BetterHelp 赞助播出。
So I talked about this before, about comparing your life to others. It can be really, really dangerous and really, really unhealthy. It's almost inevitable if you're on social media, you're like, oh, why don't I have that? Why don't I look like that? Why was my life not as great as this person seemingly?
所以我之前谈到过这个，关于把自己的生活和别人进行比较。这可能会非常非常危险，也非常非常不健康。如果你刷社交媒体，这几乎是不可避免的，你会想，哦，为什么我没有那个？为什么我长得不像那样？为什么我的生活好像没有这个人那么精彩？
And that's the thing, it's seemingly, people just post the best versions of themselves or the greatest parts of themselves. You don't know everything about them entirely. So it's kind of bad to compare yourselves to it. But I understand it's easy to do so. But comparing yourself to others is a total joy killer. It's so easy to look at someone's social media,
这就是问题所在，这只是“好像”，人们只会发布他们自己身上最好的版本或者最精彩的部分。你并不完全了解他们的一切。所以拿自己去和那些做比较其实挺糟糕的。但我理解这很容易做到。然而，拿自己和别人比较绝对是快乐的终结者。看别人的社交媒体是如此容易，
like I said, and think that they've got it all figured out. But the truth is, everyone's got their own stuff going on behind the scenes that you can't see. So therapy can help you focus on what you want instead of what others have. So you can start living your best life. If you're thinking of starting therapy, give BetterHelp a try.
就像我说的，会让人觉得他们已经把一切都搞定了。但事实是，每个人在幕后都有自己的焦头烂额，而你是看不到的。所以心理咨询可以帮助你专注于你想要的东西，而不是别人拥有东西。这样你就能开始过上最好的生活。如果你正在考虑开始心理咨询，不妨试试 BetterHelp。
It's entirely online, designed to be convenient, flexible, and suited to your schedule. Just fill out a brief questionnaire to get matched with a licensed therapist and switch therapists anytime for no additional charge. Stop comparing and start focusing with BetterHelp. Visit betterhelp.com slash smartlis today to get 10% off your first month.
它完全在网上进行，旨在提供便利、灵活性，并契合你的日程安排。只需填写一份简短的问卷，就能与有执照的心理咨询师进行匹配，并且可以随时免费更换咨询师。停止比较，开始专注，就用 BetterHelp。今天就访问 betterhelp.com/smartlis，首月即可享 9 折优惠。
That's betterhelp, H-E-l-p dot com slash smartless. Smartless gets support from ZipRecruiter. Summer's finally here! What? And all those seasonal businesses are looking to hire. Everything from mule packers to drama camp leaders. That means if you've got those special skills, you're in luck. There's a big demand for people like you, and they're not exactly easy to find. Whether you're hiring for one of those roles or any other role, how do you find
网址是 betterhelp.com（H-E-l-p）斜杠 smartless。Smartless 获得来自 ZipRecruiter 的支持。夏天终于来了！什么？所有那些季节性企业都在招人了。从骡队打包员到戏剧夏令营领队，应有尽有。这意味着如果你拥有这些特殊技能，那你可真走运了。市场对你这样的人才需求量很大，而且他们并不是那么容易找到。无论你是在招聘这些职位中的一个还是其他任何职位，你该如何在竞争对手抢先之前找到，
top talent before the competition gets to them? ZipRecruiter. And right now you can try ZipRecruiter for free at ziprecruiter.com slash smartlis. Found a candidate that really stands out? ZipRecruiter makes it easy to reach out to them right away. Just use the pre-written invite to apply message to personally connect with your topics and get them interested in your opportunity. Gear up for summer with ZipRecruiter's high-speed hiring tools. See why 4 out of 5 employers who post on ZipRecruiter get a quality candidate within the first day. Just go to this exclusive web address right now to try ZipRecruiter for free. ZipRecruiter.com slash smartless.
顶尖人才呢？ZipRecruiter。现在你可以在 ziprecruiter.com/smartlis 免费试用 ZipRecruiter。找到了一个真正出类拔萃的候选人？ZipRecruiter 让你可以轻松地立即与他们取得联系。只需使用预先写好的“邀请申请”信息，就能与你心仪的人选建立个人联系，让他们对你的机会产生兴趣。借助 ZipRecruiter 的高速招聘工具为夏天做好准备。看看为什么 5 个在 ZipRecruiter 上发布职位的雇主中有 4 个能在第一天内找到优质候选人。现在就访问这个独家网址免费试用 ZipRecruiter。ZipRecruiter.com/smartlis。
Again, that's ZipRecruiter.com slash smartless. Again, that's a ZipRecruiter.com slash smartless. ZipRecruiter, the smartest way to hire. And now back to the show. Who was your main inspiration as far as developing that style of telling stories as opposed to jokes? Was it like a George Carlin? Because I seem to remember he was kind of like that too,
再次声明，网址是 ZipRecruiter.com/smartlis。再次声明，那是 ZipRecruiter.com/smartlis。ZipRecruiter，最聪明的招聘方式。现在让我们回到节目中。就发展这种讲故事而非讲笑话的风格而言，谁对你的影响最大？是像乔治·卡林那样的人吗？因为我好像记得他也是那种风格，
right? Yeah, well, a big, Cosby was one. Oh yeah, yeah. But like that, if you go watch his old stuff, it's very storytelling, all that kind of stuff. I'm a big Seinfeld fan. Seinfeld was, he was, I kind of think, because I always looked like I tell stories
对吧？对，嗯，一个很大，科斯比是一个。哦，对，对。但就像那个，如果你去看他以前的节目，是非常注重讲故事的，诸如此类。我是个坚定的宋飞迷。宋飞，他，我觉得，因为我总觉得我是在讲故事，
but in a joke form. I try to never be too far from the laugh because the farther you are from a laugh, the bigger the laugh has to be and I don't want to put that much pressure on a laugh. So if I can just kind of keep it going and let it build, it's like, you know, it doesn't, you're just not putting the weight of the world on this.
但却是以笑话的形式。我尽量离笑话的包袱不要太远，因为你离包袱越远，那个包袱就必须得越响亮，而我不想在包袱上施加那么大的压力。所以如果我能一直保持这种节奏让它慢慢积累，这就好像是，你知道的，它不会，你不需要把世界的重量都压在这个包袱上。
You're like, you know? Because if you go silent too long, I mean, there's a point where you're like, you know, it doesn't, you're just not putting the weight of the world on this. You're like, you know? Because if you go silent too long, I mean, there's a point where you're like, well, this joke better be unreal. Yeah, yeah. Sean tried stand up, and we won't get to his opening joke, but he started so far from the laugh, and then he never got even to the same area code
你就像是，你知道吗？因为如果你沉默太久，我是说，会有那么一个时刻你会觉得，你知道的，它不会，你不需要把世界的重量都压在这个包袱上。你就像是，你知道吗？因为如果你沉默太久，我是说，会有那么一个时刻你会觉得，好吧，这个笑话最好得精彩绝伦。对，对。肖恩尝试过单口喜剧，我们就不提他的开场笑话了，但他切入得离包袱实在太远了，而且他甚至从来没有进入过和包袱相同的区号，你知道我的意思吗？就像，他从来没有真正直接瞄准过包袱。观众压根没看清它的真面目。这变成了一场演讲。根本不可能，你就会想，不，他本该，好吧，他现在永远也get不到了。哪怕用上一系列镜子，他也看不到那个包袱。它被遮挡得太严实了。
as the laugh, you know what I mean? Like, he never had actual direct sight on the laugh. They never got a clean look at it. It turned into a lecture. And there's no way, you're like, no he's supposed to go, well he'll never get it now. Even with a series of mirrors, he couldn't see the laugh. It was so obscured.
我平时在城里开车就是这样的，我只做右转弯。不过内特，你最惨的砸场经历是什么？比如你当时就想，哦，天哪，这太糟糕了，比如。对，对，有很多次，你会把原因归咎于，有一次我觉得是因为我穿的那件衬衫，所以我把那件衬衫给扔了。对，我穿了一件系扣衬衫，还把它塞进了裤腰里，
That's how I drive around town, I only take right hand turns. But Nate, biggest bombing story, like did you just like, oh my God, this is the worst, like. Yeah, yeah, there's a bunch, I mean, you'd blame it on, I had one one time I thought it was the shirt I wore, and so I threw that shirt away. Yeah, I had a button down shirt and I tucked it in,
自那以后我再也没那样穿过。哦，真的吗？对，我当时想，这不是我的问题，我当时就想，这件衬衫快把我害死了。绝对不可能是段子的原因，对，这破衬衫快把我害死了。这家伙的衬衫，这家伙到底怎么回事？我还在游轮上演出过。
and I've never done that since. Oh, for real? Yeah, I was like, it wasn't me, I was just like, this shirt is killing me. Couldn't have been material, yeah, this fucking shirt is killing me. This guy's shirt, what is this guy's deal? I've done a cruise ship.
不用多说了。对，我赢得过一次比赛，而你的奖品就是让你的职业生涯倒退五年，去游轮上表演。所以我上台去演出，你得演很多场。所以你得演，你得演一堆演出。所以你要演30场干净的，30场还得演一堆演出。所以你要演30场干净的，30场带点颜色的。我从来没有带颜色的段子，所以感觉就像我甚至不能，
Say no more. Yeah, I won a contest and your prize was to set your career back five years and do cruises. And so I go out and I'm doing it and you gotta do like, you gotta do a bunch of shows. So you do 30 clean, 30 gotta do a bunch of shows. So you do 30 clean, 30 dirty. I never had dirty, so it's like I couldn't even,
然后你还得演一场，另一场演出。所以你老实说需要，因为有时这些人会回来看多场演出。所以你需要有两个小时的素材，或者能够跟观众互动什么的。我记得我们上台时，你在刚开始时得演一场，每人大概演五分钟，
and then you would do one, another show. So you needed, honestly, because sometimes these people would come back and watch multiple shows. So you needed to have two hours of material, or be able to mess with the crowd or something. And I remember we'd go up and you would do one show at the beginning of it, you'd do like five minutes each
就感觉像是，在那个大剧场里，你差不多就是让观众知道我们是喜剧演员，我们在后面有演出，巴拉巴拉。所以另一个家伙就很棒，他知道怎么做，他在人群中打了个闪光灯，就像是知道怎么真正跟观众互动。他说，来看我的演出吧，每场演出都不一样。
and it's kind of just like, it's in the big theater and you're kind of just letting the crowd know we're comedians, we got a show back here, blah blah. So the other guy just was great and knew how to like, he shined a flash out on the crowd, like just knew how to like really play with the crowd. And he was like, come to my shows, every show is different.
他大肆宣扬它们每场都不一样。然后我上台后我说，我的，我说大家来看一场就行，也许另一场会完全一样。我当时不得不这样，我就说，千万别来看我的所有演出，大部分都会是一样的。
And he made a big announcement how they're all different. And then I went up and I said, my, I go come to one, and maybe the other one will be the same. I had to like, I was like, do not come to all my shows, most will be the same.
我没有足够的素材让每一场都不一样。所以你们可以去看他的演出，每一场都不同。所以你们可以去看他的演出。它们会是不同的。我的演出会是……然后我就去演了一场，结果是……我刚开始讲，他们根本不笑，我心想，哦，这些人已经看过每一场演出了，而我又不是那种擅长现场互动的喜剧演员。我就想，那你平时都做什么，老兄？然后我……有些家伙会说我是个……他是个海洋石油钻井工。这其实是个挺疯狂的工作。
I don't have enough material to have them all be different. So you can go to his shows, them all be different. So you can go to his shows. They will be different. Mine will be... And then I went and did a show and it was... I started it and they didn't laugh and I was like, oh, these people have been to every show and I'm not a crowd worker. And I'm like, so what do you do, man? And I've... Some guys like I'm an... he's an oil rigger in the ocean. It's actually a pretty crazy job.
我就说，那挺酷的，然后我就继续讲了。这简直太疯狂了。人们会说一些疯狂的话，比如我是个银行劫匪。我就说，那挺整洁的，老兄。你呢，女士？我当时什么也接不上。完全没法现挂。然后我还不得不跟这些人一起坐电梯。
And I was like, that's cool, and I just moved on. It's like insane. People are saying crazy stuff, like I'm a bank robber. I'm like, that's neat, man. What about you, ma'am? I had nothing. No riffing. And then I had to ride in an elevator with these people.
我在大洋中间的电梯里。听起来好像我混出名堂了。我当时就坐在那儿，戴着一顶帽子，然后我听到有个家伙一直在疯狂吐槽我，我的肩膀都快挨着他了。我只能坐在那儿硬挺着等电梯到站。哦，天哪。不过在游轮上，他们确实把干净的段子和带颜色的段子分得很清吗，那是游轮独有的吗？对，你会有那种适合小孩子来看的演出，你的一家老小都可以来看的演出，然后你还会有那种晚上11点左右的演出。那是一场仅限成人的演出。对，其实也不能太带颜色，但那个概念会更，
I'm in the elevator in the ocean. You think it sounds like I made it. And I'm just sitting there and I had a hat on and I just hear some guy just trashing me and my shoulder's touching him. And I just have to sit there and get off. Oh my God. But they do separate them between clean and dirty
你知道的，对，你只要随口爆几句粗口就行。对，我只要一聊到停车就会爆粗口，我会说，你们这群人有没有试过侧方停车，要知道，就像——这家伙太粗俗了。对，我当时甚至连一句粗口都没有。
on a cruise ship, that's exclusive to a cruise ship? Yeah, you would just have a show that's like, the kids can come to this show, your family can come to this show, and then you'd have like a night at you know, 11 p.m It's like an adult only show. Yeah, you still can't be that dirty, but it's the idea of it is a little more You know, yeah, you could have just dropped in a couple f-bombs. Yeah, I got a curse as I talk about parking I'm like you guys ever parallel part just know like this guy's filthy Yeah, I didn't even have any.
在最船上，那是邮船专属的吗？对，你就会有一个节目，比如说小孩可以来看这个节目，你的家人也可以来看，然后你会有一个晚上，比如晚上11点，那就是一个成人专属的节目。吧，你还是不能那么下流，但是它的意思是更多一点。你知道的，吧，你可以刚刚投入了几个生死急关。是的，我开口就有咒语，当我谈到停车时我就想，你们曾经平行停车吗，只是知道，比如这个傢伙是个涡蛇吗，我甚至连一个都沢有。
I didn't even have I had no dirty jokes. Like there's no I don't really I don't talk about sex or right. Like political or like there's nothing like really like that's kind of like this. What about political sex? Will you ever touch political sex? Is that something that you'd be willing to do? That I will. Yeah. If the right joke comes up. Sure. Sure. You know, it is funny.
我甚至连……我没有黄段子。就像没有……我真的不怎么谈论性，对吧？比如政治或者像……真的没什么那种类型的。政治性的性呢？你会涉及政治性的性吗？那是你愿意去尝试的吗？我会的。对。只要有合适的笑话出现。当然。当然。你知道，这挺搞笑的。
It is remarkable how How clean your stand-up is and a lot of people it's such a weird thing to have to say to point it out But I guess it is worthy of pointing out and it is to me such a testament to how profoundly funny you are And honestly, and I hope it is a badge of honor for you It should be because it really you find ways to talk about stuff, and you hope it is a badge of honor for you, it should be, because it really, you find ways to talk about stuff and you don't need to swear it. I swear like a,
你的单口喜剧能做到这么干净，真的很了不起。对很多人来说，说出这一点感觉很奇怪，但我想它确实值得一提。对我而言，这充分证明了你有多么深刻的幽默感。说实话，我希望这能成为你的荣誉勋章，它本该如此，因为你真的总能找到方法来谈论各种事情，而你不需要说脏话。我说话就像个……
like a, you know, Cosby never cursed, right? Famously never cursed. Well, let's, again, let's not try to, you know, look at, so let's not. Yeah. But. No, let's go down the avenue of Cosby and clean, you know?
就像个……你知道，柯斯比从来不骂脏话，对吧？众所周知从不骂脏话。好吧，咱们还是……别去尝试，你知道的，去关注……所以咱们还是别了。对。但是。不，让我们顺着柯斯比和干净清洁这个方向聊下去，你知道吗？
Yeah. Yeah. This guy. So Nate, wait, did you, so at home, what's it like at home? So like, do you check out, do you run jokes by your wife? Does she okay them? Is she sick of hearing them?
对。对。这家伙。内特，等等，你在家里……家里是什么情况？比如说，你会把关吗？你会把笑话先讲给你的妻子听吗？她会批准吗？她听腻了吗？
Like, what is that dynamic at home? I'll tell her, yeah. She knows about every joke that comes up. Because that's something I had to learn to when you make fun of your wife at the beginning, is you have to show love. Like, you have to show, you make fun of your wife at the beginning, is you have to show love. Like you have to show, because people, because I remember at the beginning the reaction would be like,
就像在家里，那种动态是怎样的？我会讲给她听，对。她知道每一个冒出来的笑话。因为那是我在开始时不得不学会的一点——当你在开篇拿你的妻子开玩笑时，你必须表现出爱。就像，你必须表现出……你在开篇拿妻子开玩笑时，你得表现出爱。就像你必须表现出来，因为人们……因为我记得在刚开始的时候，大家的反应会是……
well why are you married? And so then you're like, well that's not, that's not what I want. You don't need to have that reaction. So you have to then make fun of yourself, but with her, and you got to do it in a way that where they're like, they can tell that you do love your wife. You love your family, you love your family.
“那你为什么还要结婚？”然后你就会想，“好吧，那不是……那不是我想要的。”你不需要那种反应。所以你必须拿自己开涮，但要和她一起，而且你得用那种能让人看出你确实爱你的妻子的方式。你爱你的家人，你爱你的家人。
And so it's just kind of like just making fun of each other. But yeah, I'll run by stuff. But that comes across, and you do that bit about the guy coming to replace the water heater in your other special. And you go, finally the guy realizes you don't know what you're talking about. He thinks maybe this is a modern relationship.
所以这就像是互相开玩笑。不过是的，我会把东西拿去过审。但这种感觉确实传达出来了，在你的另一场专场里，你演了那个关于有人来你家里换热水器的段子。然后你说，最后那家伙意识到你根本不知道自己在说什么。他觉得这也许是一段现代关系。
And he says to the guy, is your husband here? And then you go, yeah, I think she's here somewhere. It's so good. And it is, like you said, you're self-deprecating. You're the butt of the joke, which I think is always such a winning combo. You're not making fun of somebody. You're not having a laugh at somebody else's expense.
然后他问那家伙，“你丈夫在家吗？”接着你说，“对，我想她大概在哪儿吧。”这太棒了。而且正如你所说，你是在自嘲。你是笑柄，我觉得这永远都是一种稳赢的组合。你不是在取笑别人。你不是在拿别人的痛苦当笑料。
You're not putting somebody else down to make yourself funny, which is great. Yeah. I just never liked it. Like, I felt bad. I mean, I would, like, make fun of my buddies and comics and stuff. But in the audience, you just...
你不是通过贬低别人来让自己显得好笑，这太棒了。对。我就是从来不喜欢这样。我觉得挺不好意思的。我的意思是，我也会拿我的哥们儿和同行们开玩笑什么的。但在观众面前，你只是……
I just always felt, you know, it's like, this person's just trying to sit there. They don't need to be, like, big. What's your shirt? Your shirt's stupid. And then I got my shirt on tucked in, right? Don't we all got stupid shirts? Do you still live in Tennessee? Yeah, I moved back.
我总是觉得，你知道，这就好像这个人只是坐在那里试着看演出。他们不需要被……“你的衬衫是什么鬼？你的衬衫太蠢了。”然后我把衬衫塞进裤子里，对吧？难道我们不都穿着蠢衬衫吗？你现在还住在田纳西州吗？对，我搬回来了。
So I was gone like 13 years. And then we've been back for about nine. Yeah, I hear it's beautiful down there. Yeah, it's so good, right? Yeah, I'm born and raised there, it's great. We have as much of a normal life as it can be. We're gonna live in a cul-de-sac, the house at the top, so we have the leaders.
所以我离开了大约13年。然后我们搬回来大约九年了。对，我听说那里风景很美。对，真的太棒了，对吧？对，我在那里出生长大，好极了。我们的生活尽可能地过得正常。我们住在一个死胡同里，房子在最顶端，所以我们就是老大。
And we set the tone for it. I have a joke, I'll just say it's my new act, Russ, and we do all, in our cul-de court of state, we do all the right things. Like if someone pulls down there, we're like, what are you doing down our street? Any car we don't know, we just run out, and they're like, you better get out of our court of state. I mean, just furious if they come down there.
我们来定基调。我有一个笑话，我就直说这是我的新段子，罗斯，我们在自己的死胡同社区里，我们做所有正确的事。比如如果有人开车开进那条街，我们就会说：“你在我们这条街上干什么？”任何我们不认识的车，我们都会冲过去，他们就会说：“你们最好从我们的死胡同里滚出去。”我是说，如果他们开到那儿，我们会气得不行。
Brothers and sisters growing up? I have a younger brother and a younger sister. Oh yeah, so you're the oldest of the three. And do they, are they finding you funny all the time? Or like, yeah? Yeah, yeah, my brother's like three years younger than me. My sister's about 10. I've talked about her in a special,
你们一起长大的有兄弟姐妹吗？我有一个弟弟和一个妹妹。噢，对，所以你是三个孩子里最大的。他们……他们会觉得你一直都很好笑吗？还是说……对？对，对，我弟弟比我小三岁。我妹妹大约十岁。我在专场里提过她，
and she works for me now too. So that's fun, I mean, you get yelled at by her. I mean, you got your whole family, you got your sisters working for you, and then you're on tour with your mom and dad and your aunt, and I mean. Yeah, I feel old though, that's cool. It's pretty rad.
她现在也为我工作。所以这挺有意思的，我的意思是，你会被她大声训斥。我的意思是，你的整个家族都在，你的妹妹为你工作，然后你还和你的爸爸妈妈还有阿姨一起去巡演，我的意思是……对，不过我觉得自己老了，这挺酷的。这相当棒。
I don't think you've said this, but you have kids, sorry, do you have kids? Yeah, I have an 11 year old daughter. Why are you so nervous to ask him that, Jason? By the way, he's married, he said he's not available. What are the kids' ages? I did say before, don't ask about if I have kids. Yeah, he's married. He said he's not available. What are the kids ages? I did say before don't ask about if I have kids Alright, I guess okay Yeah, I have one eleven year old daughter
我觉得你还没说过这个，但你有孩子吗？抱歉，你有孩子吗？对，我有一个11岁的女儿。杰森，你为什么这么紧张不敢问他这个？顺便说一句，他结婚了，他说他名草有主了。孩子们多大了？我之前就说过，别问我有没有孩子。对，他结婚了。他说他名草有主了。孩子们多大了？我之前就说过别问我有没有孩子。好吧，我想……好吧。对，我有一个11岁的女儿。
Oh, okay, eleven year old daughter and what does it seem like she's gonna want to do with her life? Does she want to uh she loves horses right now? I don't know expensive. That's expensive. It is. I don't know why. Oh, that sounds expensive. That's expensive. It is. I don't know where... No one... We don't come from horse stuff, you know? You're not horse people? No, there's never horse people, but she loves horses. So right now she's kind of doing that stuff.
哦，好吧，11岁的女儿。她看起来想用她的人生做什么？她想……她现在喜欢马吗？我不知道。这很昂贵。那很贵。确实。我不知道为什么。哦，听起来很贵。那很贵。确实。我不知道哪里……没人……我们可不是养马的人，你知道吗？你们不是马术世家？不，从来都不是养马的人，但她喜欢马。所以现在她就在搞那些东西。
But she's very creative, very funny, and she, you know, will get me and my wife laughing a lot. You know, and like... I think I got you gotta teach her where to where the joke, you gotta be like, all right, well you gotta be serious. Yeah, isn't that funny? It's like there's the age when they learn sarcasm, they learn humor, but they don't yet know when to stop the joke, they don't know when to do the joke,
但她非常有创意，非常搞笑，而且她……你知道的，经常把我逗得哈哈大笑，还有我妻子。你知道的，而且……我觉得你得教她哪里……该在哪里抖包袱，你得说：“好吧，那你得认真点。”对，这难道不搞笑吗？就像当他们学会讽刺、学会幽默的那个年纪，但他们还不知道什么时候该适可而止，不知道什么时候该抖包袱，
but you don't wanna shame them because you don't wanna kill their spirit or their sense of humor, so you just gotta kinda grin and bear, with so many things in their life. It's so incredible watching kids learn things that we forgot that we learned, you know? Like it's amazing, you know nothing until you learn it.
但你又不想羞辱他们，因为你不想扼杀他们的精气神或幽默感，所以你只能对生活中的很多事情咬牙忍耐。看着孩子们学习我们已经忘记自己是怎么学会的东西，真的是太不可思议了，你知道吗？就像这太神奇了，在你学会之前你什么都不懂。
She can make fun of her friends recently, but then they all got like, it was like they did not like it. And I was like, and it was funny, I forget what it was, but it was something funny, but you're like, all right, you gotta understand. You're like, you gotta, some people will be able to handle it, like, you know, she just is all about the joke
她最近开始取笑她的朋友，但后来他们都觉得……就像他们很不喜欢那样。我就觉得……而且这挺好笑的，我忘了具体是什么了，但挺搞笑的，不过你就会想：“好吧，你得明白。”你就得……有些人能够承受得住，比如，你知道的，她就是满脑子都是包袱，
because it's obviously just our, you know, her grandfather's a magician, a comedian, like, so it's a lot of joking. I think, yeah, I think that making fun of your friends is not a good path to go down. It's not a success right now. Unless it's Sean, I mean, it's such a big button to hit. No, I thought we were talking about friends.
因为这显然只是我们的……你知道的，她外公是个魔术师、喜剧演员，所以有很多开玩笑的成分。我觉得，是的，我觉得取笑你的朋友并不是一条好路子。现在看来这并不成功。除非是肖恩，我的意思是，这是个太显眼的笑点不能不踩。不，我还以为我们在聊朋友呢。
Yeah, Sean is fun. Oh, right. Yeah, I feel warm inside. Where's that, what's after Syracuse? Where do you go next? Albany so Of course, yeah, and what and just fucks connected II like what are you doing, dude? Yeah? Yeah? This is the route I know we started last night. We were in Philly at the
对，肖恩很有趣。哦，对。是的，我心里暖洋洋的。那儿是哪儿？锡拉丘兹之后是什么地方？你接下来去哪儿？奥尔巴尼，所以……当然，对，还有什么……真他妈有联系……我到底在干什么，老兄？是吗？这就是我所知道的路线，我们昨晚出发的。我们在费城的……
Far like it was where the sixes play no way big thing and then it then it goes Syracuse And then I'll go Albany and then that's these are the two the Fallon wanted And then it goes Syracuse and then it'll go Albany. These are the two that Fallon wanted to come to, with Syracuse and Albany. Yeah, of course. Those are big venues. I think he's from up here. Yeah. He is.
远得像……那是76人队打球的地方，绝不可能，太盛大了，然后紧接着……然后就去了锡拉丘兹。然后我要去奥尔巴尼，然后……这些是法伦想要来的地方。然后就去了锡拉丘兹，然后接下来去奥尔巴尼。这些是法伦想要来的地方，锡拉丘兹和奥尔巴尼。对，当然。那些都是大场馆。我猜他是这里人。对。他是。
He's from upstate New York. What arena or place are you playing tonight in Syracuse? The arena. The Carrier Dome, probably, right? Is that what it is? No. Is that used to be? No? Yeah. No, I've been to a game there. That's like a huge... You know the arena the carrier dome probably right is that what it is no Yeah, no, I've been a game there. That's like a huge
他来自纽约州北部。今晚你在锡拉丘兹哪个体育馆或场馆演出？体育馆。卡里尔穹顶体育馆（Carrier Dome），大概吧，对吧？是那个吗？不是。那是以前的吗？不是？是吗？不是，我去那里看过去比赛。那是相当巨大的……你知道那个体育馆，卡里尔穹顶，大概吧，对吧？是那个吗？不是。是，不是，我去那里看过去比赛。那是个巨大的……
Okay, I've been a basketball game there you could fill in basketball courts set up It's your people buy tickets that are like I don't think they could see the court Right they're sitting like behind the court would there be a crowd That's just too big for for a comedy show was's just like, it needs to be a little bit more intimate, like 20,000 people is like right at the max, maybe, or no? Yeah, I mean, it's all about how you make it feel. We have, like, you know, the arena is we have these big screens, we have, I've put more speakers up so everybody
好吧，我去那里看过篮球比赛。你可以在那儿铺上篮球场，然后摆好。你的观众买的票是那种……我觉得他们根本看不到球场，对吧？他们坐的位置就像在球场后面，现场会有观众吗？那对喜剧演出来说规模太大了，就好像……需要更亲密一点，比如2万名观众大概就是极限了吧，还是说不是？对，我的意思是，关键在于你营造的感觉。我们有……你知道的，体育馆里有这些大屏幕，我们装了更多扬声器，好让每个人
can hear it everywhere, and you really do try to make it intimate, I mean, you can tell everybody gets real quiet. I mean, that's the cool, it's one of the coolest things is when you're telling a joke and you're, this many people are quiet. Yeah. I really do try to make it intimate. You can tell everybody gets real quiet. It's one of the coolest things is when you're telling a joke and this many people are quiet. I could yell with no microphone and the top person could hear me. It gets that quiet. I could see it getting a little... And we're in the middle, too, of an arena,
在任何地方都能听见，你确实在努力营造那种亲密感，我的意思是，你能感觉到所有人都变得非常安静。我的意思是，这很酷，最酷的事情之一就是当你正在讲一个笑话，而这么多人都在安静地听着。对。我确实在努力营造亲密感。你能感觉到所有人都变得非常安静。最酷的事情之一就是当你正在讲一个笑话，这么多人都在安静地听着。即使不用麦克风我也能大声喊出来，坐在最高处的人也能听到我。现场能安静到这种程度。我能想象这会变得有点……而且我们也处在体育馆的正中央，
so I'm a lot closer to everybody. Do a hundred thousand, do a hondo. Come on, do a hondo. Do the big house at Michigan. Have you ever had a moment where you kind of scare yourself a little bit by thinking about all the eyes that are looking at you and that they're not talking
所以我离每个人都要近得多。弄个十万人的，弄个超级大的。来吧，弄个十万人的。去密歇根大学的那个大体育场。你有没有过这样的时候，当你想到所有那些看着你的眼睛，而且他们都不说话，
and that it is silent and that you might not be doing well and you can't leave for another 45 minutes. Are you scared of the eyes? I mean, if you ever had a panic attack on a stage and know that you can't leave for another hour. I have. Yeah, I mean, you've done it so long now that you're... I mean, keep your knees bent. It's happened to me.
现场一片死寂，而你可能表现得并不好，并且在接下来的45分钟里你都无法离开，你想到这些时会不会有点自己吓自己？你害怕那些眼睛吗？我是说，你有没有在舞台上经历过恐慌发作，却知道你在接下来的一个小时里都无法离开？我有。对，我的意思是，你演了这么久，以至于你……我是说，保持膝盖微曲。这确实发生在我身上过。
I mean, it's like... Yeah, yeah. I mean, I've done it now. It's like, yeah, I mean, you think about it. I had an SNL, like a little bit, when I did the monologue. I was more nervous with the monologue because it's like stand up and you're like, I'm supposed to be good at this.
我是说，这就好像……对，对。我的意思是，我现在已经习惯了。这就好像，对，我的意思是，你会想到它。我上《周六夜现场》（SNL）的时候，做那个独白的时候稍微有一点。我做独白时更紧张，因为这就像是单口喜剧，而你会想：“我本该擅长这个的。”
And then you got to kind of deliver the jokes into the camera, but there's the crowd. And so like, it was very weird to deliver jokes to kind of a spot where no one's at. Right, and you're right on the heels of sitting, of standing back behind that flat, behind the band, right? That little narrow little plank. And the whole crowd is silent and they're counting down
然后你得把笑话对准摄像机讲出来，但现场还有观众。所以就像……对着一个空无一人的地方讲笑话感觉非常诡异。没错，而且你刚从那个平面布景后面走出来，就站在乐队后面，对吧？那个狭窄的小台子。全体观众一片寂静，他们正在倒计时
to that live moment to America. Like it becomes really tangible. Like you're not just live in front of a crowd, it's beaming across the planet. Like it's real tangible there. Yeah, you're like I can say anything right now and they're gonna hear it right now because it's live.
迎接面向全美直播的那个时刻。这种感觉变得非常真切。就像你不仅是在一个观众面前进行现场表演，它还是通过无线电波传遍整个星球。那种感觉在那里是如此真实。对，你会觉得：“我现在可以口无遮拦，他们立刻就能听到，因为这是直播。”
Yeah, remember when I used to remember like 20 jokes when I was a kid, I used to love them. And now I can only remember like one or two, but from back then, no, they're not that great. Go tell one, Jay. Do you have any jokes? You wanna hear a guy tell a joke inside out? Go ahead.
对，还记得我小时候能记住大约20个笑话吗，我以前特别喜欢它们。现在我只能记住一两个了，不过是以前的，不，它们其实没那么好。去讲一个吧，杰。你有什么笑话吗？你想听一个人从里到外讲个笑话吗？来吧。
I do get a little tripped up. Do you have a joke from when you were a kid that you'll never forget? You may not use it in your act, but it's just like, just a classic that was one of your favorites? Yeah, I didn't use it in my act. You say you do? I hang, no.
我确实有点磕巴。你有什么小时候听过、永远不会忘记的笑话吗？你可能不会把它用在你的演出里，但它就像是一个经典，曾经是你的最爱之一？对，我没有把它用在我的演出里。你说你有？我挂了……不。
I didn't hang on to your like, I kept it. I still read a joke book when I was five and I'm closing on it. I remember the joke, I said there was a joke book or something and there was a guy goes, waiter there's a spider, or there's a fly in my soup. And then the waiter goes, well don't worry, the spider on your bread will get it.
我可没抓着你的……就像，我把它留下了。我五岁的时候还在读笑话书，现在快要……我还记得那个笑话，我说当时有一本笑话书什么的，里面有个家伙说：“服务员，我的汤里有一只蜘蛛，或者有一只苍蝇。”然后服务员说：“哦，别担心，你面包上的蜘蛛会搞定它的。”
And there was a picture of a spider bread. And so my dad always brings it. I remember that joke and then my dad brought it up because I was explaining why the joke was funny to him and kind of going through it. Here's why this is funny. So that one was the first one, but I let it go. I never used the joke.
上面还有一幅面包上趴着蜘蛛的画。所以我爸总是提起这个。我还记得那个笑话，然后我爸把它提起来了，因为我当时在向他解释为什么这个笑话好笑，顺便捋了一遍。这就是为什么这很好笑。所以那是第一个，但我后来把它放下了。我从来没用过这个笑话。
Do you guys have jokes from when you were a kid that you'll never forget? One joke that's appropriate to tell? Is there one like a go-to that you remember? I had a joke book when I was really little. It was, you know. You have a joke book now, but anyway, keep going. It was, it's not funny.
你们小时候有没有永远不会忘记的笑话？有一个适合讲出来的笑话吗？有没有哪个是你一想就能记起来的保留节目？我小时候有一本笑话书。那是……你知道的。你现在也有笑话书，不过总之，继续说。那是……这一点都不好笑。
It was funny when I was like six years old. It's like, where do dead people go in your house? And it was the living room. I have one which is like, people always say that ballet is really hard to do, and so I always say just don't do it. Yeah. Oh, see Nate laughed.
我大概六岁的时候觉得它挺好笑的。就像是：死掉的人在你家里会去哪里？答案是：起居室。我有这么一个段子：人们总是说芭蕾舞真的很难跳，所以我总是说，那就别跳呗。对。哦，看，内特笑了。
Nate laughed at that. That was Sean's opening joke when he did stand up. And what is it, this would probably be interesting for folks, including me. What are the, how do you do the economics of being a standup? I'm assuming you have to bear all the costs of the trucks and the infrastructure and all that stuff,
内特听到那个笑了。那是肖恩做单口喜剧时的开场笑话。还有什么……这对大家来说可能挺有意思的，包括我在内。作为一个单口喜剧演员，经济账是怎么算的？我假设你必须承担卡车、基础设施以及所有这些东西的所有成本，
and then you get to keep whatever you don't spend on what it costs to put the show up, right? And you're making your money based on ticket sales and merchandise, perhaps, full stop. Yeah, yeah, I mean, merch is not the biggest thing in stand up. Why? Yeah, I don't know. We've had it, we've done it at shows,
然后你能留下筹办演出所花成本之外剩下的所有钱，对吧？你赚钱的基础是门票销售和周边商品，也许吧，就这样。对，对，我的意思是，周边商品并不是单口喜剧最主要的收入来源。为什么？对，我不知道。我们在演出时弄过，
and it's just, it's not like a concert, or people don't, like I was saying, stand up's still kind of, it's kind of a newer thing. Like Cosby's like one of the first, he's still alive. And like, you know, he knew Lenny Bruce. And then Carlton. Don't, you gotta, if I could give you one piece of advice. If we could just lose the Cosby references.
但它就是……它不像演唱会，人们不会……就像我刚才说的，单口喜剧依然算是一种比较新的事物。比如柯斯比可以说是第一批人之一，他还活着。而且，你知道的，他认识兰尼·布鲁斯（Lenny Bruce）。然后是卡尔顿。别……如果你能听我一句劝的话。如果我们能不用那些柯斯比的梗就好了。
If we could get it. That was the multiple. Well, if we could get it down to single digits, it would be great. Yeah. You guys, all right. Or, you know what, I'm gonna just. Louis C.K. was.
如果我们能……那可是个多发点。好吧，如果我们能把这方面的引用控制在个位数，那就太好了。好吧，你们。或者，你知道吗，我打算直接……路易·CK曾经……
I'm gonna send you a couple articles. Harvey Weinstein and I once set up an LLC. But, but, but, so But so you've got this huge. Apparatus. Yeah, apparatus, right? But you could do without it. You get like a deal. So you have promoters and then the, yeah, you are,
我要给你们发几篇文章。哈维·韦恩斯坦和我曾经一起成立了一家有限责任公司。但是，但是，但是，所以……但所以你拥有这样一个庞大的……机构。是的，机构，对吧？但没有它你也能行。你就像是签了个协议。所以你有推广商，然后……是的，你……
I think it's like the promoter's the one that's putting the money for like the renting of the venue. And then I'm paying, then it comes out of mine, the show budget of the speakers and all that stuff. And so you can have it go as low or as big as you want it to go. Who's your manager, who are your peeps? Brillstein, Brillstein in UTA.
我觉得就像是推广商出资来租场地。然后我来付钱，从我的演出预算里扣除，包括音响和所有那些东西。所以你可以让它的规模按你的意愿可大可小。谁是你的经纪人，你的团队都有谁？布里尔斯坦（Brillstein），布里尔斯坦和UTA。
Yeah. We'll be right back. Smartless is brought to you in part by Audible. Listening on Audible helps your imagination soar. Whether you listen to stories, motivation, expert advice, any genre you love, you can be inspired to imagine new worlds, new possibilities, new ways of thinking. Find the genres you love and discover new ones along the way. Explore bestsellers, new releases, plus thousands of included audiobooks, podcasts,
and originals that members can listen to all they want, with more added all the time. Audible makes it easy to be inspired and entertained as part of your daily routine without needing to set aside extra time. There's more to imagine when you listen. Guys, I'm listening to The Housemaid is Watching by Frieda McFadden.
I can make fun already, that title makes me freak out and spooks me out. It's really, really good. The New York Times said, it's an unbelievably twisty, tension-packed and globally best-selling Housemaid series. The book can be enjoyed as a standalone listen, and once you start, it will have you up all night
until the final explosive twist. You guys, you gotta check it out, it's so good. As an audible member, you can choose one title a month to keep from the entire catalog, including the latest bestsellers and new releases. New members can try Audible free for 30 days. Visit audible.com slash smartless or text smartless to 500-500.
That's audible.com slash smartless or text smartless to 500-500 to try Audible free for 30 days. Audible.com slash smartless. free for 30 days, audible.com slash smartless. Smartless gets support from Vanta. Whether you're starting or scaling your company's security program, demonstrating top-notch security practices
and establishing trust is more important than ever. Vanta automates compliance for SOC 2, ISO 27001, HIPAA and more, saving you time and money while helping you build customer trust. Plus you can streamline security reviews by automating questionnaires and demonstrating your security posture with a customer-facing trust center
all powered by Vanta AI. Over 7,000 global companies like Atlassian, Flow Health and Quora use Vanta to manage risk and prove security in real time. Get $1,000 off Vanta when you go to vanta.com slash smartless. That's v-a-n-t-a dot com slash smartless for $1,000 off. A little birdie tells me Colin that you, in your youth, were quite a promising distance runner.
Middle distance on Tell Cider. Which is something that Mo Farah managed to avoid. And really that's the only difference between the two of us. Everything to play for is back with a two-parter to celebrate Olympic summer, Paris 2024, on Mo Farah. Of all of the athletes we could have chosen, why Mo Farah? Well, he's a distance running icon. He did the double, double, 5,000 and 10,000 metre gold at two Olympics. One of those gold medals for him, part of Super Saturday, maybe the most famous day in British Olympic history.
It's fantastic to see Sir Mo Farah, but what a career Brendan or Steve. Follow everything to play for on the Wondry app or wherever you get your podcasts. You can binge seasons early and ad free right now on Wondry+. All right, back to the show. By the way, backing way up to the beginning of this interview, what is Bargazzi?
What is the nationality of Bargazzi? Italian. Oh, it is? First of all, don't spit it out like that. What is Bargazzi? What the fuck is haze? Son of a bitch. What the fuck is wrong with you?
Shunk, you wigged this hair. Sorry, Nate. Jesus. No, fucking Shunk. I mean, I do it, but I... And by the way, what the fuck is Bargazzi? Bargazzi. I've just never heard of Bargazzi.
This has really been a bee in my bonnet for a minute. How do you even spell that? I know, I can't even begin to spell it. I knew that, but I forgot that I knew that. Italian, wow. I think we say it wrong as a family, too. I think it's supposed to be bargotzy, and we say barget.
It's just we've southerned it up. Oh, I say bargotzy. Yeah, I think a lot of people would. Don't people say bargotzy? When I lived in New York, they would always be like, bargotzy, because it's like Italian, and I was like, you know. I was like, I don't like tomatoes.
Do you have family in Italy? I don't, you know. You don't know, yeah? I think we've all agreed to kind of go. We had a family reunion once, and we had family come over from Italy, and we got Kentucky Fried Chicken for them. And I think it was like, from that moment, was just kind of like, all right, y'all have a good life, from Italy and we got Kentucky Fried Chicken for them.
And I think it was like from that moment was just kind of like, all right, y'all have a good life. We did it. We're going to do our thing. We're going to do y'all's thing. And we just kind of got in our separate ways. Nate, what do you like to do in your free time? And you've got a lot of time like on a bus or you're touring or on the plane or whatever. What do you watch? What are the things, are you a sports guy?
Do you watch other stand-ups? Do you watch? Is it Candy Crush? How are you occupying your minutes? Yeah, I'm a big sports guy. So I watch a lot of golf, like any sports. Golf, UFC, Winslow UFC. Oh, you do?
Yeah, I'm a big fan of UFC. I wanted to peg that. I wanted to peg you for a big UFC. It's just the most, the honesty of it, with like, Dane the White just, and the fighters, they can say whatever they want. And so there's no, you know, like when Tom Brady is, he go retire, not retire. It's like, it's all kind of a game and a show. And UFC kind of really is like, we just got a dude that just says,
I want to fight this guy Right and then it just gets to it and you're I don't know I kind of like I love but there's there's no romance to that too though, right? Like they kind of there's the build-up to it I mean then they get in the you know, then they don't like each other and then you're you know And then you go in there watch them fight. It's not just watching a street fight You're watching two professionals that have to like fill each other out Yeah and watch them fight, it's not just watching a street fight, you're watching two professionals that have to, like, fill each other out. Yeah. So you watch, uh, UFC, you watch golf,
you like to play golf, you play golf when you're on the road? Some. It gets hard, but it's... because of the shows and stuff, but yeah, I'll play some on the road. Yeah. Yeah, yeah. I mean, that's, uh, it's kind of it. I mean, I don't know, it's like you're just running around, got a lot of stuff, got a lot of hanging out.
Like, the road is the most fun, because it's just, like, a bunch of dudes, and, you know, this's like you're just running around, got a lot of stuff, a lot of hanging out. Like the road is the most fun, because it's just like a bunch of dudes. And you know, this morning we went in, we're in Syracuse and this place has a hot and cold plunge thing. Sure. And uh, so I've never done it.
And then so, but they let us come in. So like we woke up and did that. Wait, who's Boo Weekly? I saw something. Oh yeah. What is that? So, this is another, I told it on Eskimo, I told it in my act too.
But Boo Weekly, cause I have a joke about fighting orangutan at a county fair. Okay. Okay. And where I read the story was, there's a golfer named Boo Weekly. And when he read, he said when he was 15,
he got in he goes this county fair he's from like Georgia like seven seven Georgia it's like the 80s you know and there you could pay five dollars to fight an orangutan orangutan would be in a boxing ring with boxing gloves so dude you pay five dollars to fight him and that's hysterical. Yeah, and then guys would get in there and this orangutan would just knock people out. Because when I say this, I tell the whole story in my act, but I say because we didn't have the internet to look up how strong is an orangutan.
You have, it was all word of mouth back then. So, you know, you had to meet a guy that just fought an orangutan. And he's like, he's stronger than you think. You know, but the arms are so skinny. You know, I know. That's what I thought as well. And the reach. It's the reach. It's the jabs. Look at his feet. His feet's bigger than you.
Yeah, that strength comes from somewhere. And they'll rip your face off too if they want. Well, that's what Buwigi said. He goes, that's not written everywhere back in 1982 when you're fighting a regular the guy that does this doesn't go all you sign a waiver And sure yeah, you don't realize till afterwards like that's why he has gloves on if this thing if it gets the gloves off There's a chance. It will rip your head off So but you know what are you, ride the scrambler again? Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. That's really funny. Oh, I wonder if that's still in existence anywhere in the country. I bet there's still a place. So, I think PETA got ahold of a lot of this.
Sure, sure. They knocked those things down. And that one, they were like, you can't do that. We're like, all right. We thought they liked it. I'm glad you just had to tell us and we got rid of it. Fair enough. Nate, what are you going to do today before the show? Tell them you're busy.
It was this and then, yeah, it was just this. I don't have any like, I got to read, I'm messing up the order a little bit, so I'll do that a little, and then we're just hanging out and be at the venue if there's, we do try to shoot basketball, like some of these arenas, if they have a basketball goal somewhere, we try to like mess around, shoot basketball, just kind of, you know, do whatever until showtime.
And then you're going on tour, you got a new special, you're shooting a new special. In Phoenix, yeah. You love Phoenix, you tour, you got a new special, you're shooting a new special. In Phoenix, yeah. You love Phoenix, you did your last special in Phoenix. I did my last special there, and this one's gonna be in the Footprint Center where the Suns play. So it's, yeah, it's, yeah, I mean, it just kind of works out like touring wise,
like you just hit these towns like every two years or so, and so it's just kind of like. And your wise. Like you just hit these towns like every two years or so. And so it's just kind of like. And your family goes with you? Or do they stay home? They do some, yeah, yeah. We went to Europe, like they came to Europe. They come to the, you know, they're not here in Syracuse or Albany, but they,
if they're, I'm doing the Boston Garden, they're gonna come to Boston. Tell them to join you out in Phoenix and for some of the best pizza in the world as voted by the voters. By the people. At Chris Bianco's. At Chris Bianco's pizza.
Nate, can you do, I saw you do this one thing a long time ago. You don't have to do it, if you're like, I gotta go. But one of the funniest things I ever saw you do. Sorry, sorry, dude. You want me to stand up and do my act? Do you mind? I mean, can you just... Just show us your tits real quick and then go to show. Would you mind doing it topless? Sorry just... Just show us your tits real quick and then go to show us.
Would you mind doing it topless? Show us your tits real quick. No, one of the funniest things was, it was a story about your meeting your wife's ex-boyfriend. Yeah, on the boat? Yeah. I went, yeah, we went, I got to remember it, but we went to, it happened. We're on the lake, Old Hickory Lake. Is that true?
Yeah, and we're in, we're like in the water, and then it's, my wife's ex-boyfriend was on another boat. Right. And I didn't see him, and she pointed it out, like there's no reason to point it out. But she pointed it out. So then, yeah, like all I can think of now, like I'm thinking about him. And then I look at her and she's looking at him and I feel like she's looking at him to see what her life would be like if she didn't marry me. And I was looking at him to see what my life would be like if I didn't marry her. So we're both putting
a lot of pressure on this guy. And then my buddy told me, he's like, you should go fight him. And I was like, boy, he's on a boat. Like, I gotta swim over to that fight. Have you ever tried climbing a boat from water? It's not graceful, it's not easy. You don't come in with power.
I would need his help to start the fight. It's not easy. You don't come in with power. I would need his help to start the fight. I think that was it. Yeah. That was so funny. But I just, we can all relate to meeting exes. Our current exes.
I don't know if you guys did. It's never good. Yeah, I don't. I don't really have exes. All right. Well, Nate. What are you talking about, Nate? You're not king on a second.
I know, but that's what made it frustrating. I had no one to go show my wife, well here's mine. It was, I just got to meet. What do you mean? Cause what is she, your high school sweetheart or something? No, we started dating like 20, 21. We met at Applebee's. We both waited tables at Applebee's.
I was a host at the time. Oh, that's great. I love that host at the time. That's great. I love that. You don't need to scream. Yeah. I mean. Little stuff is going. Sounds like it's all good in the neighborhood.
What are we? Yeah, we're all in the neighborhood. We're all in the neighborhood or something. Yeah, in the neighborhood. But we're big fans. We took our daughter. What was your favorite thing on the Applebee's menu? Here we go.
They had the chicken broccoli alfredo. I'd get no broccoli, you know? Yeah, I hear ya. And then I'd say put it on the side just so the guy thinks I'm going to eat it, then he would just take a full plate of broccoli back after. I go, ah, I got full on the other stuff. Uh.
It's, there's. That's so true. Like we're worried what they think, yeah. Yeah. Watch this, do you think that's impressive? Sean, Applebee's menu backwards. Go. Cobbler, Applecobbler.
Of those kinds of restaurants. Chinese chicken salad, pretty good. I'll eat that. Every place makes a Chinese chicken salad now. That's kind of like the new molten lava cake. Every place has a Chinese chicken. What makes it a Chinese chicken salad? Just because of the ginger dressing?
They're the only ones that don't eat it. No. And those crispy noodles. The crispy noodles and the... Yeah, you get the crispy... Chin chin, no, listen, Sean, I don't have to tell you. Chin chin. Chin chin does the best one.
只有他们不吃那个。不。还有那些脆面。脆面和... 对，你吃到脆的... 琴琴（Chin Chin），不，听我说，肖恩，我不用跟你多说。琴琴。琴琴做的是最好吃的。
One of the best ones. One of the best ones. One of the best ones. Sean's telling his Chin Chin Chin. Wait, so of all those kinds of restaurants, I forget what you call them, are they big box restaurants? Yeah, chain restaurants. Chain restaurants. Have y'all not been to one in a while?
数一数二的。数一数二的。数一数二的。肖恩在说他的琴琴。等等，所有那种类型的餐厅，我忘了你们叫它们什么，是大盒子餐厅吗？对，连锁餐厅。连锁餐厅。你们大家最近都没去过吗？
Like, you gotta just go. It's been a minute, but I did like to, and your new special, Nate says, everything I learned, I don't know a lot that came from a big, like a building, like a higher education building, everything I learned I overheard at a Target or a Lowe's. The Lowe's, yeah, the line at Lowe's.
就像，你必须得去一次。虽然有一段时间没去了，但我确实喜欢，正如你的新专场里内特（Nate）所说，我学到的一切，我不知道有多少是来自什么大型建筑，比如高等教育建筑，我学到的一切都是在塔吉特（Target）或劳氏（Lowe's）无意中听到的。劳氏，对，在劳氏排队时。
Everything I overheard at a Target or a Lowe's. Yeah, we're big chain. I mean, I grew up, like we're, you know, I had an old joke about, like I was a big, I don't like mom and pop shops, because they can close, close just they're like we don't feel good today and they close like Walmart Walmart, you know, they were mom pop shops at some point and then they became they got it together and became unreal. Yeah So yeah, I like those. Yeah, I like mom. Here's what I like. I like chilies and I'm not afraid to say They have the great chocolate lava cake.
我在塔吉特或劳氏无意中听到的所有东西。对，我们喜欢大连锁。我的意思是，我长大的时候，你知道，我以前有个老笑话，关于我不喜欢夫妻老婆店，因为它们说关门就关门，它们会说今天感觉不好就关门了，而像沃尔玛沃尔玛，你知道，它们在某个阶段也是夫妻老婆店，然后它们把业务整合起来，变得不可思议。对，所以，是的，我喜欢那些。对，我喜欢妈妈。这是我喜欢的。我喜欢奇利餐厅（Chili's），而且我不怕承认。他们有超棒的巧克力熔岩蛋糕。
If you want one, go to Chili's. Go to Chili's. They used to have the Southwest egg rolls or whatever. They used to have those things. Me and Dax used to always go to, God, I love it, Chili's. What about Outback? They any good with the Bloomin' on you? Yeah, yeah, we go to Outback a good bit.
如果你想吃一个，就去奇利餐厅。去奇利餐厅。他们以前有西南卷饼什么的。他们以前有那些东西。我和达克斯（Dax）以前总是去，天哪，我太喜欢了，奇利餐厅。那Outback（澳拜客）呢？他们的洋葱花球（Bloomin' Onion）还行吗？对，对，我们经常去Outback。
Scotty worked at TGIF. Oh, I used to love Out. That's good too, that's fun. That's an intimidating menu. Dr. Pepper's doing some pretty amazing things right now. So if you are into Dr. Pepper, Diet Dr. Pepper, they got some real good stuff going on. And some cherry, right? They got some, like some cream soda, strawberry stuff.
斯科蒂（Scotty）曾在星期五餐厅（TGIF）工作。哦，我以前也喜欢Out。那个也不错，很有趣。那是个让人眼花缭乱的菜单。博士胡椒（Dr. Pepper）现在正在做一些相当惊人的事情。所以如果你喜欢博士胡椒、健怡博士胡椒，他们有一些非常棒的产品。还有一些樱桃味的，对吧？他们有一些，比如奶油苏打水、草莓味的东西。
I mean, it's something, dude. They're showing off over there. Did we ever get any confirmation on the doctor portion of the Peppered? Like did we ever see documentation to prove that he graduated? He suggested diet. What kind of doctor was he? Yeah, I mean, I do like diet Dr. Peppered too. And I'm going to say this, I like their ads. I like their TV ads. I think they're funny, the College football ads. I think they're real clever.
我的意思是，老兄，那可真不简单。他们在那儿秀呢。我们从来没有得到过关于胡椒博士的“博士”头衔的确认吗？比如我们有没有看到证明他毕业的文件？他推荐的是健怡版。他到底是什么博士？对，我的意思是，我也确实喜欢健怡博士胡椒。我要这么说，我喜欢他们的广告。我喜欢他们的电视广告。我觉得它们很有趣，大学橄榄球广告。我觉得它们真的很聪明。
Nate, before I let you go, how do you know Greg Garcia? How did that happen, this son of a gun, speaking of son of a guns? So I've tried to make a bunch of shows that are never gone. We've had one show that we shot a pilot. And so Greg came in, I did not know him, but he came in, Danielle Sanchez-Whitsell. She was showrunning it, and she's friends with Greg.
内特，在我让你离开之前，你怎么认识格雷·加西亚（Greg Garcia）的？这事是怎么发生的，这个混蛋，说到混蛋？所以，我曾试图制作一堆没有成功的节目。我们有一个节目拍过试播集。然后格雷就加入了，我以前不认识他，但他加入了，丹妮埃拉·桑切斯-维策尔（Daniela Sanchez-Whitsell）。她是剧集统筹，她和格雷是朋友。
And so Greg came in to help us do it. And I knew Greg Garcia's work, but I didn't know him when he first came in. So when he first came in, he's like, he's going to help us. And I was like, I don't know who this dude in so before he first came in he's like he's gonna help us and I was like Oh, this dude is yeah I gotta listen to this guy and then we wrote our whole rewrote the whole script on his off Just his ideas because they were so good and Obviously, he's unreal and so we just become really close and become friends. I I was just with them this week
所以格雷进来帮我们做这个。我了解格雷·加西亚的作品，但他刚来的时候我不认识他。所以他刚来的时候，他说，他要来帮我们。当时我就想，我不知道这这家伙是... 所以在他刚来的时候，他说他要帮我们，当时我就想，哦，这家伙是... 对，我得听听这家伙怎么说，然后我们根据他的意见重写了整个剧本，仅仅是因为他的点子太棒了，显然，他简直不可思议，所以我们变得非常亲密，成了朋友。我最近刚和他们在一起
actually really close and become friends. I was just with him this week, actually, at dinner with him, because I had to go to LA for a second. So, yeah, we became friends like that. He comes out on the road too. I'm telling you, y'all should, y'all come out on the road. If you want to get away and have a little fun trip, come on out.
其实真的非常亲密，成了朋友。我这周其实刚跟他吃过晚饭，因为我得去一趟洛杉矶。所以，是的，我们就这样成了朋友。他也去巡演。我跟你说，你们应该去，你们也来巡演吧。如果你想逃离日常，度过一次有趣的小旅行，那就来吧。
Dude, that would actually be really, really fun if you mean it. It's a fun day. If you mean it. I swear, Fallon's coming tonight. We have a fun time. It's you just, uh, we play cards and you play, uh, you know, like we went to a casino last night in, uh, uh, Sean. I mean, first of all, this is your dream. They go to casino and they're going to chain restaurants. I mean, you know, every single, every Cracker Barrel's got skin marks in front from Sean's carve.
老兄，如果你是认真的，那其实真的、真的很搞笑。那是个有趣的一天。如果你是认真的。我发誓，法伦（Fallon）今晚要来。我们过得很开心。你就是，呃，我们玩牌，你玩，呃，你知道的，就像我们昨晚去了一个赌场，在，呃，呃，肖恩。我的意思是，首先，这就是你的梦想。他们去赌场，然后去连锁餐厅。我的意思是，你知道，每一个... 每家粢饭大王（Cracker Barrel）门前都有肖恩的汽车尾气留下的划痕。
Cracker Barrel is one we didn't touch on. I've not been there, but I hear that's the one. Anywhere that can handle bus parking, it's all chain stuff. Well, Greg Garcy is one of the all time great guys. Super, super funny guy. One of the funniest pranks, he always, I'm not really like a big pranks guy, but he is so funny, I had a long joke and a prank,
粢饭大王是我们没聊到的一家。我没去过，但我听说那是必去之地。任何能停下大巴车的地方，全都是连锁店。好吧，格雷·加西亚是有史以来最伟大的人之一。超级、超级搞笑的人。最好笑的恶作剧之一，他总是，我其实不是那种喜欢搞大恶作剧的人，但他太搞笑了，我有一个很长的笑话和一个恶作剧，
and I just, he's such a great guy. So yeah, that makes sense that you guys would be pals. Well, listen, I'm gonna return the offer and say next time you're out here in California, let's go play golf, man, and hang out, and grab some lunch. Such a huge fan of yours, dude. Honestly, you're just the funniest, funniest, funniest.
我只是觉得他是个如此好的人。所以，是的，你们能成为死党就说得通了。好吧，听着，我要投桃报李，说下次你在加州的时候，咱们去打高尔夫球，老兄，然后一起出去玩，吃个午饭。你巨大的粉丝，老兄。说实话，你简直是太搞笑、太搞笑、太搞笑了。
So funny, it's so good to see you. So exciting to see you, just more and more and more people. Appreciate you. Really happy for your success. Truly, truly, truly. Yeah, man. Thank you, yeah, thanks for having me on. Nate, thank you for doing this.
太搞笑了，很高兴见到你。很高兴见到你，越来越多、越来越多的人。感谢你。真心为你的成功感到高兴。真的、真的、真的。是的，老兄。谢谢你，是的，谢谢你邀请我上节目。内特，谢谢你来做客。
What a thrill. Thank you for saying it. What a thrill. All right, the great Nate Bergazzi. Thank you, buddy. Thank you, Nate. Thanks, Nate. Thank you, guys. See you, man this. What a thrill. Thank you for saying it. What a thrill. All right, the great Nate Burgoszi. Thank you, buddy. Thank you, Nate. Thanks, Nate. Thank you, guys.
真是太荣幸了。谢谢你这么说。真是太荣幸了。好吧，伟大的内特·巴尔加齐（Nate Bargatze）。谢谢你，老弟。谢谢你，内特。谢谢你，内特。谢谢你们。再见，老兄。真是太荣幸了。谢谢你这么说。真是太荣幸了。好吧，伟大的内特·巴尔加齐。谢谢你，老弟。谢谢你，内特。谢谢你，内特。谢谢你们。
See you, man. Have fun. Bye. The great Nate. The great Nate. The great Nate. God, is he funny. Yep.
再见，老兄。玩得开心。拜拜。伟大的内特。伟大的内特。伟大的内特。天哪，他怎么这么搞笑。是的。
Old, like old school, clean, good, hilarious, nonstop fun. Hilarious, God. He just seems like a real kind fella, you know? Yeah, I can't see him getting upset. I'm sure you could figure out a way to piss him off. How would you, what would be your strategy if you really wanted to get Nate pissed off?
老派的、干净的、好的、搞笑的、永不停歇的乐趣。搞笑，天哪。他看起来就像个真正善良的家伙，你知道吗？是的，我想象不出他生气的样子。我确信你能找到办法把他惹毛。你会怎么做，如果你真的很想把内特惹毛，你的策略是什么？
I'd ask him questions over, I'd ask him the same thing over and over again like I didn't understand. No, I think he'd be very patient with that. I don't think that would be his button pusher. No, but like if you just went on and on about something like you just really honestly truly didn't understand, I think it pisses anybody off. I wonder.
我会一遍又一遍地问他问题，我会把同一件事问上一遍又一遍，就好像我听不懂一样。不，我觉得他对那样的事情会非常有耐心。我不认为那是能触动他神经的按钮。不，但如果你对某件事没完没了地唠叨，就好像你真的、老实说、真心听不懂一样，我觉得那会把任何人惹毛。我想知道。
Like what are you not getting, right? Yeah, yeah. You know what I mean? No, but we have a pretty high threshold. We have a pretty decent amount of patience for you in that regard. What is the thing that gets you guys to anger quicker than anything else?
就像你到底哪里不懂，对吧？对，对。你知道我的意思吗？不，但我们的阈值相当高。在这方面，我们对你有相当可观的耐心。到底是什么事情能比其他任何事都更快地激怒你们？
Stupidity. Stupidity, yeah. People who don't think like I do. I have a short fuse for stuff I don't suffer. I have a short fuse for like, yeah, people who are incompetent or like can't, like don't have common sense about like easy things. And then in the meantime,
愚蠢。愚蠢，对。那些思维方式和我不同的人。我对那些我无法忍受的事情缺乏耐心。我对那些无能的人，或者说，对于简单的事情缺乏常识的人，我的耐心很短。然后与此同时，
I'm the dumbest person on the planet and I probably do the same thing. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I hate when people like punch down, you know? Yes. When they're like mean to people cause they know they can be.
我是地球上最蠢的人，我可能也在做同样的事。对。对。对。我讨厌那种喜欢向下践踏（punch down）的人，你知道吗？是的。当他们对别人尖酸刻薄，因为他们知道自己可以这样做时。
Oh yeah, well that's, yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah. It's like so lazy. Yeah, yeah, it is. Punch down either, especially if it, you know, we do do a lot of joking around and we love to sort of rib each other and stuff, but anytime I see somebody who likes to,
哦，对，那真是，对。对，对，对。这太懒惰了。对，对，确实是。也不要向下践踏，特别是如果它，你知道，我们确实开了很多玩笑，我们喜欢互相开玩笑什么的，但每当我看到有人喜欢，
and we talked about it with Nate, who likes to get a laugh at somebody else's expense. Yeah, yeah. Or you know what else pisses me off? Confident ignorance. That can also be super funny though. Yeah, yeah. Or you know what else pisses me off? Confident ignorance. That can also be super funny though. Yeah, sometimes. Well, in a character it can be.
我们和内特谈过这个，喜欢建立在牺牲别人的痛苦之上的笑声。对，对。或者你知道还有什么让我恼火的吗？充满自信的无知。不过那有时也会超级搞笑。对，对。或者你知道还有什么让我恼火的吗？充满自信的无知。不过那有时也会超级搞笑。对，有时会。好吧，作为一个角色来说确实可以。
Right, you have to do it on purpose. But yeah, a person who is much smarter, or much more confident than they have a right to be, is just grading. Because you have to spend an effort to convince them that you're buying it. Right. But if you have no dog in that fight and you're just observing that person, it can be hilarious.
对，你必须是故意的。但是，是的，一个比他有资格表现得更聪明、或者更有自信的人，简直令人恼火。因为你得花精力去说服他们你在买账。对。但如果你和那场争论毫无干系，而你只是在观察那个人，那可能会非常搞笑。
Oh yeah. That is true. By the way, I love playing those characters. The character that's just an alpha everywhere, and then the tough guy walks in and then they're beta, hi, beta. Right, right, right, right, exactly. But Nate, we should go see his show when he's out. He's so funny.
哦，是的。确实如此。顺便说一句，我很喜欢扮演那些角色。那种到处都是老大（alpha），然后一个硬汉走进来，接着他们就变成了小受（beta），嗨，小受。对，对，对，对，没错。但是内特，他来演出时我们应该去看他的秀。他太搞笑了。
I think we should meet him in Phoenix and go get some of that Bianco pizza. And then play some golf over there. You're not playing golf anymore. Not till October. I have to be disciplined. You know? I know.
我想我们应该在菲尼克斯（Phoenix）和会合，去吃点那种比安科（Bianco）披萨。然后在那里打几场高尔夫。你不再打高尔夫了。直到十月。我必须保持自律。你知道吗？我知道。
I mean, we can go to Nate's We could go to his show and like participate or we can go and just be a bunch of by SmartLess. SmartLess. SmartLess. SmartLess. SmartLess. SmartLess. SmartLess. SmartLess. SmartLess. SmartLess. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjarf, and Bennett Barbico.
我的意思是，我们可以去内特的……我们可以去他的秀场然后参与其中，或者我们可以去，只是做一群由 SmartLess 带来的…… SmartLess。SmartLess。SmartLess。SmartLess。SmartLess。SmartLess。SmartLess。SmartLess。SmartLess。SmartLess。SmartLess 是由迈克尔·格兰特·特里（Michael Grant Terry）、罗布·阿马尔杰夫（Rob Armjarf）和贝内特·巴尔比科（Bennett Barbico）100%有机且以手工精心制作的。
SmartList If you like SmartList, you can listen early and ad free right now by joining Wondry Plus in the Wondry app or on Apple podcasts. Before you go, tell us about yourself by filling out a short survey at Wondry.com slash survey. Hey, it's Guy Raz here, the host of How I Built This, a podcast that gives you a front row seat to how some of the biggest products were built, and the innovators, entrepreneurs, and idealists behind them. Every week I speak to someone new. Stories like Justin Wolverton's, a lawyer who just wanted a healthy alternative to ice
SmartLess。如果你喜欢 SmartLess，现在就可以通过加入 Wondry App 或苹果播客上的 Wondry Plus，提前且免广告收听。在你离开之前，请在 Wondry.com slash survey 填写一份简短的调查问卷，告诉我们关于你的信息。嘿，我是盖伊·拉兹（Guy Raz），《我是如何建造它的》（How IBuilt This）的主持人，这个播客让你能够第一排见证一些最大规模产品的建造过程，以及它们背后的创新者、企业家和理想主义者。每周我都与一个新面孔交谈。像贾斯汀·沃尔弗顿（Justin Wolverton）这样的故事，他是一名律师，只是想要一个健康的冰淇淋替代品，
cream, so he created Halo Top in his Cuisinart. Or Todd Graves, who grew his fried chicken restaurant Raising Canes into one of the most successful fast food chains in the U.S. All of these great conversations can help you learn how to think big, take risks, and navigate crises in life and work from people who've done all of that and more. Follow How I Built This on the Wondery app or wherever you get your podcasts. You can listen to How I Built This early and ad free
于是他在美膳雅（Cuisinart）搅拌机里创造了 Halo Top。或者托德·格雷夫斯（Todd Graves），他将自己的炸鸡餐厅 Raising Cane's 发展成为美国最成功的快餐连锁店之一。所有这些精彩的对话都可以帮助你学习如何在大局上思考、承担风险，并从那些经历过这一切及更多的人那里，学会在生活和工作中驾驭危机。在 Wondry App 或你获取播客的任何地方关注《我是如何建造它的》。你现在就可以在 Wondry+ 上提前且免广告收听《我是如何建造它的》。
right now on Wondery+. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。